first we heard
one of the alternate jurors a woman who
didn't know she was an alternate
we heard her say that she didn't want to
go through the riots and the destruction
again and she was worried that someone
would show up to her house and retaliate
this of course in the derek chovin trial
then we heard about another juror who
came out and talked about his time on
the jury
this time a photo emerged showing him
wearing a shirt that said
get your knee off our necks black lives
matter he had attended a black lives
matter rally
where some of the speakers were family
members of george floyd this man as a
juror
said he would be impartial and also said
in a questionnaire that he did not
attend any of these protests
pertaining to police brutality i suppose
he's trying to play the semantic game of
well the rally was something totally
different in dc that was about you know
martin luther king jr
not police brutality even though floyd's
family spoke there
about police brutality so yeah he lied
and now this on top of a whole bunch of
other reasons
has the the defense the defense lawyer
for derek chopin
filing for a new trial to impeach
as it were the verdict essentially
overturning it this isn't just an appeal
this is outright saying we need a new
trial because this whole thing was
broken now a lot of
media outlets are saying it's about this
one juror it actually doesn't even
mention the juror for the most part just
mentions juror misconduct
which is probably all you really need
and then maybe when he goes to argue it
but i'll tell you this
he's presenting this to to the the judge
in the case
as if that judge is going to give them a
new trial
the judge thinks it's fair right we'll
see how this plays out we got a bunch of
other stories though and louis i think
it's in louisville a guy pulled a gun on
a black lives matter protest and
actually they pulled the gun first i
think then this other guy pulls a gun
tensions are getting hot so we're going
to talk all about this joining us today
is the ever wonderful former
congressional candidate and founder of
red renaissance kim klasik
thanks for having me do you want to
briefly introduce yourself sure
uh so i ran a mirrorless congressional
district number seven this is my second
time here
again thanks for having me back
different building um yes yes
beautiful um and you know i wasn't
successful in my bid
but i learned a lot right you fail you
fail forward you learn those lessons
and uh even though we lost like i said
you know we got
a lot gained and so we started a pack
called red renaissance
and we're supporting minority candidates
across the entire country
that are running in the districts they
grew up in that they've been doing
community work in and they're
more america first candidates so we the
people
not towing the party line cool right
ian's chilling
yeah hanging out man ian cross on what
up good to see you buddy
and i am here in the corner pushing
buttons happy to have kim back with us
again in our new studio
oh yeah man i'm looking at all the
stories we have pulled up and i'm like
man this summer is going to get nuts
it's just going to be
fires and brimstone i got to say it is
ridiculous that if this guy wants to
impeach the trial verdict that he has to
go to the same judge
it's great you gotta you gotta appeal
outside of
what is the point right well before we
get into all that go to timcast.com and
become a member
by clicking this big old blue members
only button you can then go to the
members area where we have a bunch
of exclusive segments for members only
really really great stuff
people seem to really love these two
these two two of these videos we had jim
hansen talking about
california new york losing congressional
seats we also did this really great
discussion with michael knowles about
god faith and religion and spirituality
and science and dmt and all of that
crazy stuff
but we're definitely going to have a
members only exclusive up tonight
after the show so if you want to see
this you got to become a member
in the event we get banned which i think
is increasingly likely when you look at
what's going on i mean
look if they're not going to get a fair
trial for
a cop then i think it's fair to say
it's going to get pretty bad for the
rest of us censorship is probably going
to get worse
and uh well if you want to support us
and even that happens you'll find all
our content here at timecast.com you can
become a member
let's jump into this first story before
we do smash the like button hit the
notification bell subscribe to this
channel
and leave us a good review if you're
listening on on on a podcast platform
give us five stars
here we go here's the here's the big
story from wcco cbs minnesota derek
chovin's attorney files motion for
new trial they report attorney eric
nelson has filed a motion for a new
trial for former minneapolis minneapolis
police officer derek chovin
in the death of george floyd nelson
filed the motion on the grounds of juror
misconduct
and that the court abused its discretion
for failing to agree to the defense's
request for a change of venue
and sequestering the jury i'ma stop
right there it's actually substantially
more comprehensive than that
this kind of feels like local outlets
are trying to downplay the defense as
they keep doing
it's particularly annoying see the
filing comes in the midst of a
controversy surrounding a photo
of juror brandon mitchell at the march
on washington last august last
august which included speeches from
george floyd's family members
he is seen wearing a t-shirt that says
get your knee off our necks
in his juror questionnaire mitchell
wrote that he had not attended any
protest over police brutality
mitchell told wcco monday that he was at
the march in support of ramping up voter
turnout that doesn't matter
they didn't ask did you go to a police
brutality protest
for another reason they said did you he
said no
he lied here's what gets crazy this dude
is interviewed in a podcast called like
get up erica i think it is get up
mornings with eric or something
where he's asked about jury duty says if
you want to effect change i'm
paraphrasing you got to get on these
juries to affect
change i mean right then and right right
there you see his motivation
he wanted to get on the jury he lied to
get on the jury because he wanted a
guilty verdict that is not
impartiality but let me pull up the
actual file and then we'll start
we'll get into this check this out so
this is the actual legal filing
notice of emotion and motion they say
to the above named court the honorable
peter a cahill
judge of hennepin county district court
and matthew g frank
assistant minnesota attorney general
maybe the attorney general will take
this and go gee these are great
arguments i'm going to have a new trial
for chauvin
but i really doubt the judge cahill
receiving this is going to do anything
other than no ignore it so this is
this is the defendant's notice of
motions and post-verdict motions they
say
they're they're filing a motion for an
order granting a new trial
saying on the following grounds the
interest of justice abuse of discretion
the depr the deprived i'm sorry
abuse of discretion that deprived the
defendant of a fair trial
prosecutorial and jury misconduct errors
of law at trial
and a verdict that is contrary to law
the specific basis for this motion
include but not
but are not limited to they they say
they didn't change the venue
they abused its discretion when denied
the motion for a new trial on the
grounds of publicity during the
proceedings
threatened the fairness of the trial say
the court
failed to sequester the jury the state
committed pervasive
pre-prejudicial prosecutorial misconduct
which deprived chauvin of his
constitutional rights to due process in
a fair trial including
but not limited to disparaging the
defense improper vouching
and failing to adequately prepare its
witnesses the court abused its
discretion and violated children's
rights
under the confrontation clause when it
failed to order
maurice hall to testify or in the
alternative
to admit into evidence mr hall
statements to law enforcement regarding
his interactions with floyd
moyester hall was according to floyd's
girlfriend their drug dealer who was
there with george floyd
he pled the f he pleaded the fifth and
there were questions from the defense as
to why
the prosecution would not grant him
immunity and
order subpoena him to testify maybe
some people assume it's because they
want to charge this man later with
murder with the murder of george floyd
or at least have that open as an option
but they could have said you'll be
immune from prosecution now testifies to
what happened they didn't do it
we got more the court abused its
discretion when it submitted
instructions to the jury that failed to
accurately reflect the law
with respect to second-degree
unintentional murder third-degree murder
and authorized use of force they say it
violated
mr chauvin's rights when it permitted
the state to present
cumulative evidence with respect to use
of force that's interesting i guess
they're saying
there should have been one expert saying
here's what the policy is and be done
with it but they brought in multiple
people saying just different things
the court abused its discretion in
violation of chauvin's rights
when it ordered the state to lead a
witness on direct examination
they say they also failed so here's i
think this i
uh in the in the uh in the motion it
failed to order
that a record be made of the numerous
sidebars that occurred during trial
and they say j the cumulative effect of
multiple errors and these proceedings
deprived mr shoven of a fair trial
in violation of his constitutional
rights and then it finally gets to
two because it was one abcd you know you
get it two it says an order for a
hearing to impeach
the verdict pursuant to minnesota r crim
p
26.03 subdivision 206 and
schwartz v minneapolis suburban busco on
the grounds the jury committed
misconduct
felt threatened or intimidated felt
race-based pressure during proceedings
and or failed to adhere to instructions
during deliberations in violation of
chauvin's constitutional right to due
process
and a fair trial they say a motion for
an order granting the defense additional
time to thoroughly brief the above
issues
and any other relief deemed fair and
equitable equitable by the court
the motion is based upon the files and
records in the case yeah you get the
point
and i really really doubt this will go
anywhere but
okay now that we've gotten through all
that the trial wasn't fair
in my opinion i don't know what uh what
you guys think and i don't think there's
going to be a new trial
but if there is i don't know how many
buildings you think they'll burn down
this time
oh gosh that's the problem that's the
problem
seven that's a great number um a good a
good solid number seven
can't go wrong something's gonna be more
than that could be at least seven yeah
so they can't put this appeal until
after sentencing right
isn't that how this works this is a
motion for a new trial okay yeah i'm not
sure at worst i'm not a lawyer
i don't think this is an appeal i think
they're outright saying
the court is out of order you all need
to give us a new trial
i really doubt i doubt they're gonna do
that the judge was all
the judge already refused to do all of
these things listed
right like we're gonna have a trial
right here in the city while the city is
on fire
i'm sure that jurors will be fine about
that yeah the guy had a black lives
matter shirt on
at a protest the juror who says
to effect change you've got to weasel
your way you didn't say weasel get
get against these germans you don't get
one to effect change you get on a jury
to be a neutral arbiter
i i actually agree with what he said
it's not about like
for activism purposes you know maybe i i
just i disagree with the spirit of what
he said
but the idea is if you want to be if you
want positive
change in your community you've got to
be active in civics you got to get on
juries
and and when someone's accused of like
i'll tell you this if i was on a jury
and this is what
this will disqualify me from all future
jurors related to gun you know gun laws
if i was on a jury and they were like
this young man you know chicago inner
city young black man has a handgun
and they're like he's being charged with
felony possession i'd be like i've i
vote to nullify
during nullification that means you can
as a juror choose to say he's not guilty
even if they instruct you
like they give you instructions where
they say if the law says you can't have
a gun
and you believe he had a gun then he's
guilty you can go nah
i don't think it should be illegal to
have a gun so if it were me on a jury
i'd be like nullify you you got to have
a pretty
damn good case to to get beyond
reasonable doubt what do they do
in those cases if you're like the lone
juror that mistrial
so how long will they will they
deliberate until they're like we can't
it's a mistrial
i mean i don't know i'm not a lawyer i'd
imagine it could be theoretically quick
if you were just sitting there with your
feet up you're like i will never change
my mind
like and i just plug your ears and go
they might come out and be like he's not
gonna budge we're not unanimous
there's no you know not unanimous so i
wonder if they could charge this juror
separately dude they should i think he
should get uh
i think he should get perjury yeah or
something they should they should but i
don't i mean that wouldn't affect
sheldon
in any way so no i mean if they did it
would it would
probably force a new trial but they're
not going to do it because
the the judicial system is look man the
the the crazy terrorists got their way
they went around smashing up buildings
setting fires breaking windows and
you know uh cowardly cahill that's what
i call him he's the judge
just gave in and didn't didn't treat
this uh appropriately he could he could
have just said look we can't do the
trial here any reasonable person would
suggest as much
and he said no he kept the trial in a
place that's just absolutely ridiculous
and then he made those comments about
maxine waters remember he said
oh this could end up right and then he
keeps going forward
and you're just like dude what he was i
my opinion he was scared
that if he said okay we're going to move
venue he'd get the pig's head at his
house
you heard about the juror the witness
who got a pig's head at his house
i heard the metaphor i know that
actually happened during the shoving
case yes one of the witnesses for the
defense
his old house had a pig's head and blood
smeared on it this is like mafia tactics
dude it's it's terrorism and guess what
it worked
these people got what they wanted yeah
honestly
a new trial if you truly believe he's
guilty
i can't imagine you would have a problem
with another trial you know what man
we've already heard from these leftists
who are saying why do we even need a
trial we watched it on video
it's like dude because you have no idea
like man man
imagine how how stupid that statement is
because we've heard it from many
leftists saying we all sat on video
imagine i walk up to you ian
and i punch you in the face as hard as i
can right
and then you defend yourself
but when the police arrive they say you
hitting me and you get arrested for it's
like old school bully tactics
yep so you can't just look at a video
and say
that like that's a definitive proof of
something
well point in case remember the capitol
hill insurrection
with brian sicknick remember it came out
that he was hit with the fire
extinguisher and not killed him
and then it came out later it was
national car like natural causes
right and so everyone said well we saw
the video he got hit in the head and
then people were like that's how he died
and then they came back and said no he
had two strokes
you know when i started doing all the
live streaming stuff i had
journalists telling me like now that now
that we have this like live on the
ground reporting you can't fake news
anymore and i was like what do you mean
it's easier than ever to fake news
live streaming has made it easier to
fake news because people
believe they're watching raw real
footage it's so
easy to just it like lying is always
easy and and abusing people's trust is
always easy it's it's scary it's
unfortunate
and we can see how the corporate press
takes advantage of that so you can't
just look at a video
and and most of us did i think almost
all of us did we watched the video and
we were angry
about it and then all sudden more
information came out and i think a lot
of us got embarrassed that we jumped the
gun on that one
i thought shoving was so guilty and
villainous and then i saw the second
video
of of uh what's his name why can i not
remember this guy's name sometimes yeah
george floyd
just like kicking and and whining about
how he can't breathe before he
even like in the car yeah like pushing
himself out of the cop car
and then he's on drugs i'm like what am
he's on fentanyl and meth and like oh my
god and
but that that first video was burned in
my it was still burning my brain i was
just able to kind of compartmentalize it
and i don't know if many people can do
that yeah
yeah well i thought it was weird the
defense attorney kept saying
like in his closing statement he said
any reasonable cop would have done this
any reasonable cop would have done not
and i said well i don't know if any
reasonable cop would have knelt on him
for that long as he was already subdued
and i thought
to me that was a hard sell you know
because he was already in handcuffs
he wasn't really moving around i thought
any reasonable cop i know
would have stood up except i think it
was the prosecution's own witness who
testified they did the same thing
really that's why i'm like watching this
trial and i'm just confused as to how
this verdict came about
other than the jury walked in the room
as soon as the door closed
one guy goes i don't want anyone burning
my house down can we just say guilty we
all agree guilty okay
but we can't just come out right now and
say so how about we just order some
pizza
watch ratatouille yeah come back in the
morning and then say guilty
and make it seem like a done deal i
would think that maybe they could blur
obviously maybe not but blur the jurors
faces out and
modulate their voices and let us listen
to the deliberation
i just feel like at this time anybody
could be found out at this point yeah
and so i felt like and then the way
maxine waters was talking about it i
just felt like
they had no way out man if i was on a
jury like that
i just i just put my feet in like nah
and they'd be like we all want to go
home and no one wants their house burned
down i'll be like
okay i got time yeah not guilty
uh i'm sorry not guilty does not mean
he's innocent of any wrongdoing it means
there's reasonable doubt
you don't have to prove his innocence
you just have to doubt
the official story from the state the
state won it's
it's amazing the state are the are are
they they scapegoat chauvin
he's the problem but i i want to mention
this one one quick thing back to that
earlier point
i'm pretty sure it was the prosecution's
witness that on cross-examination by the
defense
was asked have you ever subdued
somebody and held them down until ems
arrived and he said yes i have
it's like okay thank you so the jury can
hear that
you also had the use of force experts
say chauvin could have used a less
uh uh he could have used more force if
he wanted to he chose not to and then
nelson the defense was like so chauvin
chose to use a lesser force option
instead of just immediately could have
tased him unconscious basically he
chopin could have jumped out of a car
walked right up and just stuck the taser
right in the floyd according to
the state's own witness so it's it's
very very obvious
there's no fair and impartial jury here
and i i'd be really surprised if
cowardly cahill
actually decided to do this no the city
doesn't care they're all crooked they're
all corrupt
they're just look look i warned about
this
a year ago a year before this the more
the mob
wins in thing in situations like this
the more they're allowed to get away
with this violence like now in portland
we're hearing
they're they're dropping felony charges
even on antifa people who confessed
the more they do this the more people
realize they're untouchable
the more you'll get judges dropping to
their knees and and
and just groveling and begging them to
leave them alone this is so wrong
that it would this appeal thing or this
goes to that judge that's so wrong they
should go to a higher court
or to some external authority that can
replace the judge
if it's found that there was impropriety
that he overlooked bro
it's it's you're right you're absolutely
right and i think it's just at this
point i think we need to recognize
what's happening
and uh here's what's happening fox news
most portland riot suspects won't be
prosecuted u.s attorney reveals
charges have been dismissed against 58
of the 97 people arrested during the
unrest last year
here's my favorite part david beauchard
admitted
he put a customs and border protection
officer in a choke hold
charles comfort was indicted by a grand
jury of civil disorder
for twice charging at portland police
officers and hitting them with a shield
and kicking a third officer while being
arrested
both men faced federal charges stemming
from their actions
but bacharach and comfort are among
dozens of portland federal arresters who
whose cases were dismissed or
are being deferred without so much as a
day behind bars
what does that mean deferred so they
basically say
we're not going to do anything right now
we could later on then eventually it
expires or something
so uh they admitted it like literally a
dude admits to
attacking cops this is why i've been
i've been harsh on on the remain the
police that are remaining right now okay
so so why is this happening though
because the police are arresting them
antifa these rioters and they're
bringing them in
and then the d.a right who is an elected
official
right then says antifa you're free to go
it's not the police
so it's like it's it's like a sorting
algorithm where the cops just are
grabbing people
and they're like i'm a neutral neutral
enforcer of the law
and then once they send all the people
the d.a the d.a goes
uh are you a democrat you're free to go
are you far left you're free to go whoa
whoa whoa
is that a maga hat lock him up throw the
book at him
uh progressive sorry about that sorry
for wasting your time ah conservative
lock them up yeah did you take a look at
what's going on what happened in new
york with like the proud boys fighting
with antifa
proud boys got four years in prison oh
yeah antifa ran away
now i guess that's the fault of the
proud boys for trusting cops that's
really
i find that really funny that these are
the kind of people that go around saying
like thank you officer thank you
so when after they got into a fight with
andyva and the cops show up the proud
boys were like hello officer
thank you here's my name and information
and the cops smiled and said
now i'm going to lock you in prison for
four years antifa they're free to go
because they left
and then that and that's that's that's
what i find particularly funny about all
this
that we've now got what a year of
the far left and antifa being cut loose
they keep arresting them they keep
getting let go
conservatives are getting like solitary
confinement for what happened
in dc just like really brutal conditions
you look at chauvin you look at what's
going on with written house and
conservatives are still sitting there
not all of them a lot of them have
actually abandoned cops at this point
but they're still sitting there going
like
i think it's okay that cops are
arresting conservatives and putting them
in prison and
then antifa gets cut loose i'm like no i
think that's pretty bad
if we stay on that track in like a year
what do you think is going to happen
all of the conservative activists who so
much has stepped foot outside
or dare open their small business
they'll get locked up
antifa can go and burn a building down
and the da's gonna be like i'm so sorry
we wasted your time sir
i'm so sorry okay okay i gotta pull back
the hyper a little bit
the guy who burned down the police
department at least he's getting prison
time yeah
but a bunch of these people who actually
set fires like one lady
uh she got charged like multiple no
actually i think if you set a building
on fire they catch you you're gonna get
arrested
they're actually gonna hold you but the
people who are literally attacking cops
are getting away with it one lady had
like five felonies they dropped the
charges let her go with no bail
and then she set fire to the police
building the union building in portland
and then they arrested her and then
released her with no bail again oh my
gosh
that's why i'm like maybe it's time to
get out of the cities and just you know
be responsible for yourself because you
can't you can't trust a system and do
its job anymore
the the uh we've we've been seeing these
stories for
months now that far left district
attorneys have been getting elected
and these are people like you know kim
fox who dropped the charge against jesse
smallett
these are the kind of people you're
getting so sure the cops are are just
following the law i'm sorry man if these
people keep electing democrats who keep
passing insane laws and electing
progressive district attorneys who won't
prosecute
progressives ah you can tell me the cops
being neutral but
they're just propping up these corrupt
democrats and these corrupt da's
so so what you're saying i think what
you're introducing is like this
two-sided coin where conservatives need
to both leave the big cities where this
is happening
because let's be real if those
conservatives hadn't been in that crowd
with antiva they never would have been
arrested in the first place
but they have a right to demonstrate
whatever as long as they're not being
violated
what do you mean conservatives in the
crowd so why what the people who were
arrested alongside of antifa in portland
what do you mean so like the people who
went in and the d.a just throws the book
at them in these big blue cities
so in new york for instance proud boys
were at an event
right and antifo was outside protesting
and everywhere the
proud boys tried going antifa would be
like staying on the street and hollering
at him
one guy got robbed they stole his
backpack so the proud boys charged at
antifa got into a fight
and then walked away gloating and
laughing about it and live streaming it
antifa ran
off and then when the cops came the
proud boys were like thank you officer
we appreciate it and then the cops
slapped coughs on them and you know not
right at that moment they got indicted
for gang violence
so i'm not saying literally at antifa
protests right the cops are going into
conservatives okay however there was one
instance i think it was in portland
where a bunch of conservatives were out
protesting
and the cops literally guarded a bunch
of antifa
i think it's i think i just find that
hilarious and then we did see
you know some people throw their blue
lives matter the thin blue line flags
and the dirt and stomp on them
but i just like you know in in this town
south of minneapolis this woman
got a couple arrest warrants i think
like nine charges because she opened her
wine and coffee bar
and the cops tracked her down in a
different state like
30 miles away in a different state and
arrested her and brought her back and
she's
going to be charged with all these
crimes meanwhile the far left gets away
with
i mean literally a couple dozen people
died in these riots
it's going to keep happening i'm
thinking about well maybe we'll talk
about this later there's a video i just
saw
of a cop pulling a girl over who was
like driving with their
kid and would start screaming at him he
was a murderer
yeah and then she was calling him like
you'll never be white you wish you were
you can't be you you're you're useless
and i was just thinking about the kid
like
the hitler youth hitler made sure to get
little kids
involved early to brainwash them when
they were like nine yeah what do you
think they're doing in schools right now
exactly
and so i'm afraid of what these kids not
just next next year
what's gonna happen but like in seven
years when these six-year-olds and
nine-year-olds are like
becoming politically active how
dangerous that
brainwashing is he has his mom saying
that horrible stuff
and she's a teacher yes maybe to a cop
right in front of him it didn't get even
reported well the
the the funny thing is i guess what
happened was the cop drove past her
so she pulled out she was driving and
she pulls out her phone so he pulls her
over
and then she's like i pulled up my phone
to record you it's like he's just
driving down the street are you nuts
yeah these people have gone insane and i
blame you
to a great degree social media it's
empowering these lunatics
then you have the grifters on the left
who don't care they just want to make
money so they'll just say whatever
then you're the true believers who are
just loving it they're they're they're
loving the media they're loving the
social media they're loving the
manipulation
and then you get seemingly regular
people losing their minds
and screaming that this cop is a
murderer who wants to be white if i'd
seen my mom do that when i was eight
to a cop i would have lost so much
respect for cops and felt so empowered
to just
just trash that that establishment oh
treat they're nothing they're never
going to harm me i can do whatever i
want in this world
as long as i call them racist or or
denigrate them for the way they look
i'm not going to blame every single cop
in every single jurisdiction for what
we're seeing in these big cities
but these big city cops are bad because
the good ones have left
for okay so we have a situation in
baltimore we have a very far left
progressive state's attorney marilyn
mosby
and it's unfortunate because i've talked
to police officers they say you know we
arrest people
we take with central booking but it
doesn't matter because they're just
going to let them go free
and so now we have a situation where
cops really aren't out doing their job
because they're sick of it because
they're like why would i be there number
one i could get in the conflict and be
called a racist right if something
happens between a white cop and a black
person
and then two they're just gonna let them
go free you know we have 11 time repeat
offenders on our streets
doing violent crimes and it's insane
and so you know our state's attorney
she's already said she's not going to
prosecute any low-level crimes so you
can be a drug dealer you could be a
prostitute you could be all of these
things
but you better wear a mask so and you
can't have a gun you can't have a gun
yes oh well the law-abiding citizens
right right the christmas
still carry permits for you yeah yeah
there's 11 time
we had someone that was arrested an 11
time repeat offender
and he ended up killing someone and so
now he's finally i guess locked up
we'll see but i mean it's crazy you know
11th time 11th
time is the charm 11th time the charm
they say yes
11. yeah i'm not surprised at all by
cops in baltimore just being like why
would i do this and i wouldn't be
surprised if then they start
quitting and then you have a shortage
which is oh we do
we're down 700 police officers and i
think they said 500 more should be on
patrol considering the population but we
just don't have it
you know why that is because the good
cops left because the cops who are like
i'm not going to support the crooked
politicians i'm not going to waste my
time i'm going to leave
and i respect them for doing it yep the
the the political system is broken in
these places
and unfortunately you know uh if if you
if
if you live in these places and you want
to know who the guilty party is you need
to look in a mirror
to uh throw shout out to v for vendetta
the regular people who keep voting in
these democrats
i mean look they had an opportunity to
elect you
they voted for the other guy they did so
so
i i i growing up in chicago it's on it's
been under democrat
supermajority for like 80 years and it
never gets better
it only gets worse and yet you have
people complain about all day every day
and i still
hear from these people just make sure
when you go vote you vote democrat and
i'm like
why look i don't care what party they
are vote for the person is going to do a
good job
but how about we stop this single party
rule in these big cities
because now what's going to happen is
the cops aren't going to do their job
700 officer shortage in baltimore it's
going to get less safe it's going to get
more chaotic and then are people
actually going to wake up to the
to the to the fact that they're voting
in bad people no they probably will just
leave it's a cyclical problem too you
mentioned earlier like if a d.a
lets people go it's like are you going
to vote for trump okay you're free to go
are you get in there like literally
whether they mean to or not or maybe
they do mean to that's political
well a political party is is deciding
the fate of these criminals
you realize in portland when this guy
admits to attacking a federal officer
and i believe it's a felony they're how
much you want to bet
at least one of these people has thought
if we actually charge this guy and
convict him he can't vote democrat
anymore
felons you know it's a dark but it's not
even that we should we should cut these
felons loose and not charge them so they
can retain their right to vote because
they we know they're going to vote for
our guy and they're making trump look
bad
uh but you get a conservative in new
york and they're gonna be like give
those people
felonies so that they can never vote
again
and there you go and then still they're
uh
i find it really fascinating i do um
when i have conversations about big tech
with with some conservatives
and they're like we shouldn't regulate
these big tech companies and i'm like
okay well you know in 10 years when your
ideology no longer exists don't come
crawling to me and you know asking for
help to spread the word i'm not going to
do it
if there's no free speech and these big
tech companies are not regulated
the same thing's happening now with cops
there are there are a lot of
conservatives surprisingly
that are tweeting the cities voted for
this let them have no cops
but i still see a lot of conservatives
who are like no no no we have to support
the officers in new york and i'm like
dude the office of new york
the officers in new york are literally
committing crimes
like we went over this the other day
when when bill de blasio illegally
appropriates money
to to paint black lives matter with
taxpayer funds in front of trump's
building and then 27 officers stand
guard
and and arrest anyone who opposes the
illegal actions of the mayor like
they're aiding and abetting a very
serious crime and corruption
do they know he broke the law to get
that thing painted ignorance of the law
is no excuse for breaking it especially
for a cop
i mean yeah you you listen if if
someone's
if if someone says hey come with me and
you walk into a bank and they hand you a
bag and say hold this bag and then pull
out a gun
and then you're standing there like i
wonder what's happening you're going to
get in trouble you're helping the
criminal
so in these cities you you have these
cops who are literally aiding and
abetting
criminal activities from very very
corrupt politicians
and and and they're saying it's not my
fault
i i didn't do it if you know someone
else should do something about it
it's not me this you well you voted for
it and i'm like okay you all voted for
it
okay everybody in this city they get
exactly what they deserve
the conservatives who remain after
losing these elections before the
election i wasn't saying this
after the election i say maybe you got
to leave these places because otherwise
what's gonna happen is
over a long enough period of time
progressive district attorneys
okay it's it's you've got you ever go to
casino you guys have been a casino yeah
okay you know casinos win the games just
have a slight margin
in their favor so when you win 10 000
off a 10 bet somehow or whatever you're
playing and
you're all cheering the casino's happy
they like that you know why
because everyone around you hears the
celebration and they start gambling more
and all that matters is that if the
house wins 50.1 percent of the time
they're profitable over a long enough
period of time they will win
and keep getting money if these big
cities are run
by corrupt far leftists and and just
de blasio people like him who are
stealing money and you have cops
supporting them
over a long enough period of time the
left and the right could be arrested in
equal numbers
the right will go to prison the left
will be released in 10 years what is
that what does that mean
a bunch of conservative felons who can't
vote and a bunch of insane violent
offenders who are voting to their hearts
content
so i think what we need to do with the
pro with the issue that we have with
policing
is we need to separate for conservatives
we need to separate out the idea
the concept of policing from the actual
police who are enforcing these bad laws
because they are bad laws this is in
fact what is voted for there are cops
who are doing bad things out there
and arresting like small business owners
and parents are just trying to work
the idea of policing i think is very
important conservatives are inclined
towards structure
they want organization accountability
and responsibility
which is what we're losing so we need to
separate out
these terrible cops that we have right
now in these big cities who are
enforcing bad laws
from the actual idea the underlying idea
of police as a whole policing how do you
how do you
how do you how do you even do that isn't
it i don't know yeah so so even
this woman who got arrested for opening
her cafe
yeah she was arrested by a local
sheriff's department you know
40 miles outside or i think what like 50
miles outside of minneapolis
so this was a small town sheriff's
department tracked her down and said
how dare you try and serve coffee during
a pandemic and
arrested her that's crazy to me because
the small town sheriffs are supposed to
be like
in your community and understand where
you're coming from and like that you
want to have your own business
and you're supposed to have that
camaraderie and it looks like we're
losing that
too seems sad you want to know what
happens next oh boy if these things keep
continuing i'm excited we got the story
from the daily mail
the moment louisville diner pulls
handgun on armed blm protesters after
they surround up market restaurant
during kentucky derby demonstration for
brandon taylor
the unidentified man is thought to have
been eating at upmarket le chasse
le chasse i don't pronounce it on
saturday night when he confronted the
group of around 50 people
uh no they confronted him he was sitting
at a table eating and they came up to
him
i love how they frame these things they
had been marching ahead of the 147th
kentucky derby over taylor's death
at the hands of police footage shows as
the diner points his handgun
uh footage shows as the diner points his
hand gun as protesters
at protesters protesters who shouted him
a female demonstrator urges the
protesters to continue moving down the
block
a police spokesperson confirmed that the
protesters were also
armed there were at least five arrests
charges include
possession of a handgun by a convicted
felon failure to disperse and evading
police according to reports well
i will just uh say very quickly
possession of a handgun by a convicted
felon that's not
that should not be a crime uh you
shouldn't lose your right to keep and
bear arms simply because you've been
committed to crime in my opinion but i
digress
this is what we're going to start seeing
i mean we've already seen
the you know in portland when as i think
it was aaron danielson took two to the
chest from the antifa guy
we're going to see more of this we saw
it with mccloskeys
antifa blm riots they're gonna be
marching through regular people are
gonna say enough
and i gotta pay homage to uh v
for vanetta again that scene at the end
of the movie where the inspector is
narrating and he says eventually someone
will do something stupid and it shows
the cop
shoot the little girl who's like wearing
the mask and refusing to abide by the
law
it's not one for one identical but
eventually someone would do something
stupid
the the writers will show up to a
restaurant and they'll show up in the
wrong neighborhood
and a bunch of the dudes they're going
to be armed and they're going to draw
their guns
and then one of these riders start
shooting somebody or the other way
around
someone shoots back yeah well it's
definitely going to get worse before it
gets better
it's definitely going to get dangerous
and that's the problem but i don't think
i feel like democrats are okay with this
you know what i mean i think they're
okay with it even getting violent
because they wanna show like look look
at these conservatives they're unhinged
they're violent they're domestic
terrorists you know that's how they want
to frame us
so i think that's why we're going to
continue seeing this cycle
well the problem is the people who vote
for democrats
don't pay attention anything oh for sure
yeah i learned that
so you don't even need conservatives to
do anything this is the other problem
conservatives are having right now i
it's just conservatives seem to think
that even though they're being cheated
if they keep playing they'll eventually
win
like something we described yesterday
it's like imagine you're playing
monopoly watching
you know this this person take money out
of the bank and just cheat and you're
like
well as long as i keep playing maybe
i'll eventually get it it's like no
they're cheating dude
yeah the immediate look the democrats
come out and they're like the biggest
threat we face white supremacy in the
far right
and there's like one riot from the from
from the right in
in you know a year or two years or i
mean probably a lot longer than that
and then you have on the left just a
year of buildings being burned is
destroyed to rubble
you had that guy at the sports bar in
minnesota where he shows up the next day
after the riots
and as he's walking in they're stealing
his safe and he's on camera crying
but don't worry the fbi is not going
after those people but they found a pole
rope and a garage and a nascar they
sent out a dozen plus agents for that
one yeah then you get the the capital
and they got billboards and they got
photos and cnn's still talking about it
it's because they have a large base
of really i don't want to be mean but
let's just say really ignorant people
who don't care
right so so biden's ratings are in the
gutter cnn's ratings in the gutter msnbc
they're all in the gutter because these
people don't care
at all they don't watch the news they're
tribalists they just want to fit in and
say whatever
whatever they have to say and
conservatives think playing a game
against them
they're going to win it yeah i don't
think so you know
i think it was michael malus he tweeted
something earlier someone said something
really dumb to him
and he responded with i don't understand
how people can be so black pill black
pilled when we're up against this
and it was like a really dumb person
tweeting and i my response was
zombies are really dumb but when they're
in hordes they overrun you
and that's what's happening right now
they don't sleep right that i know of
zombies don't sleep i don't think so i
think i think liberals do sleep but
okay yeah i think that the military
industrial complex needs a villain
to whip people into a fear frenzy and
now they're just using this capital riot
on the sixth
cnn's complicit because trump's gone
yeah trump's gone
we're not at war with a with a greater
foe at the moment so they're looking
inward to find a terror
i think i think they just are trapped in
a time warp
like january 20th came and then you know
joe biden becomes president and then
brian stelter just like hit an invisible
wall
and then he like freaks out and he's
banging like like watching everyone walk
away he can't get past this invisible
barrier
and he's just trapped in january 20th
for for eternity
like that's that think about how like a
that's like a oh that's a good idea for
a horror movie yeah
it's like groundhog day some serious
cash to watch brian stelter's dreams
oh really yes gosh i'd be curious yeah
oh my gosh like what is he does he dream
about guilt it's like
it's like it's like he's in the middle
of the night and there's he's in an old
rickety you know house just totally
dilapidated
and he's like walking through the halls
confused there's a thunderstorm and like
lightning
and then like the hallway's completely
black but when the lightning flashes
there's just trump standing in the back
and then he's running but then when he
gets to the door he he goes through the
door to get out of the house
and then or is mike panson no no no no
no as soon as he goes through the door
he immediately comes through the back
door back into the house and he's like
no
he's a batman and he's tweeting trump is
here trump is here
and then everyone else in the real world
can see his messages
and they think that he's just lost his
mind but he's really trapped in this
time vortex surrounded by evil trumps
or he's just obsessed with trump and you
can't stop talking about it
i like my version better i think it's
scarier to brian stelter with trump not
being there because he has nothing to
talk about or focus on
uh ian i don't think it's a military
industrial complex i think it's the deep
state or whatever they called it like
the unelected officials who stay in
power
the people who want but i don't like the
whole deep state things it implies that
the permanent politicians aren't part of
it
no like nancy pelosi gets elected no
matter what interesting she just like
stands there and then just like
stands on the stage and farts and
they're like yeah and they vote for her
i wonder if that's part of it like those
people that are in office for 40 years
are kind of co-opted by that system
whether they're like shaking hands with
the people that are making the decisions
or not i don't know
i think the system is just always going
to prop
up the most vapid and awful people
so terrible i mean kim didn't win no
offense
but yeah yeah the good people don't get
it you end up with people like kinzinger
did it get pelosi twisted like it didn't
always used to be twisted right he used
to
abe lincoln could win i mean yeah but
it was twisted got twisted in like the
40s or something
sometimes yeah sometimes there's a
glimmer of hope
and a saint-like hero emerges we had
donald trump
i'm kidding i'm totally kidding
statements were not connected godly yeah
no i think it's like there's for one
reason another positions are always bad
but we had it we we had a few good
people they just don't make it because
you got to be truly
vile to gain that kind of power i got to
know i mean you tell me about it what
was it like
yeah so we thought we did pretty good
but unfortunately we weren't part of the
establishment
so we didn't get support from the rnc we
didn't get support really from the
maryland gop
party you know they all had in mind who
they wanted to run in the seat and so
when i went the primary
i think they were kind of pissed and
then when a video came
out they were like whoa whoa whoa whoa
you're drawing too much attention to
a seat that we never planned on winning
we're not gonna win it we're not gonna
exhaust donors on you or volunteers
so please go sit down somewhere you know
so they were kind of pissed that we
we got so much traction i think uh
because they
you know for our governor hogan
is supposedly a republican and he's
friends with the guy that beat me quiet
who is a very establishment democrat he
was the former president of londonville
acp
he was a former congressman in that seat
before congresswoman elijah cummings
and so he is part of that swamp i guess
but governor hogan is friends with him
you know they they all are friends at
the end of the day it doesn't matter
what aisle
or side of the island they're on they're
all friends they grew up in this
they've been doing politics for many
many years and they hold true to each
other
this is why they hate trump correct
trump is
rich but he's not part of that club
they don't like him he's a he's a
bombastic weirdo
and you know i i have to imagine when he
got elected they probably were like
okay donald you got elected now here's
the plan he was like
no america first and they were like whoa
whoa whoa what what
are you talking about and then they were
like we got to stop this guy he's not
in line with what we want to do take a
look at lindsey graham
you know he walks up to kamala harris on
the floor and he's like what did you do
he fist bumped her or something
it's like i don't expect him to be all
enemies and hate each other i like the
idea that you can
not agree with someone and still be
friends with them right but i think what
you see from the likes of lindsey graham
and people like
mitch mcconnell is that you know i i i'm
calling him milk toast mcconnell
he doesn't do anything now that the
republicans have no power
all of a sudden he's like oh i'm i'm
going to fight for all the republicans
oh
yeah it's like bro you had the power you
did literally nothing with it
you don't care it's a show is it
political theater
yeah that's what it is politicians just
go there and they want to pretend like
they're doing something it's almost like
these big tech hearings we keep seeing
where it's like we've had like what
eight now or whatever
whatever the up teeth time that ted cruz
yells at jack dorsey i'm just like
uh-huh
and i i think ted cruz is all right but
at a certain point i'm just like dude
just just just stop you're not doing
anything you can't do anything
i don't care to hear you yell at mark
zuckerberg again it's performative
it doesn't mean anything like the
founding fathers were scientists
uh thomas jefferson and ben franklin i
mean franklin obviously
if not invented electricity discovered
it for our culture
yeah invented it uh thomas jefferson was
a writer a musician
i mean i don't know i know he was
involved with the sciences as well
and those are the people running the
country and we kind of need that again
not to have like
theatrical you know people they just
talk a lot and get paid
what it was is that the government
running
the colonies was thousands of miles away
so they had no choice but to have their
own local governments
and then once you do that they're like
yeah i'm even here why should we
care about what you think it takes you
like six months to actually
relay what we say to the king and back
so eventually just like
we should be independent it makes no
sense now because of the surveillance
state and you know communications and
and you know big tech and all that stuff
they can control
what you see and what you hear man it is
it is it's beyond creating it's more
about
encryption than distance now like how
long does it take the computer to crack
the encryption code on your message as
opposed to how far away is it
being sent and how long is it going to
take to get there i'd imagine they can
crack encryption
and we think they can yeah even quantum
encryption there's that quantum cracking
computers and things like that i hear
i'm willing to bet they've got quantum
computers can crack can unrival even
like the entire crypto market if they
wanted to
but they just keep that out of the
public eye so people don't know and it
allows them to maintain control
yep so i think that ian has a point
uh because in my i was thinking about
this and i was like well what would it
be like if scientists were kind of like
in charge and leading us and then i
started thinking about
ron paul and rand paul and i was like oh
yeah these are people who like work
out of the public eye who actually have
like in real life experience
unlike joe biden and bernie sanders
who've done nothing but work in the
government and i really think that could
be maybe what we need again
right i guess my question is like we all
understand that in this room
but why doesn't the majority of the
country understand it
that's a part that i don't get like it's
just so easy to see
um you know fortunately i don't know if
you guys know
congressman jb raskins he was kind of
yeah yeah yeah i'm all about the
impeachment but
a guy read against him that i support
his name was greg cole and he's a rocket
scientist
oh wow yeah and he's like i just don't
know how to really get my name out there
and i was like i'll help you as best i
can
like a very intelligent guy but he still
lost to jamie raskins who does
absolutely nothing
and it's like of course these
politicians they're politicians they
can't really do
much because they'd be out of a job so
you know it's just
it's this continuing cycle but there's
people now that are so upset
you know with what's going on in the
political arena
and now it's like you have all of these
people hating each other before it
wasn't this
bad you know it wasn't as polarized uh
it's easier to cheat yeah and by cheat i
mean like
sock puppet accounts on social media
fake opinion polls
manipulation propaganda is easier than
honest
arguments right it's really tough to to
have a real argument with someone
it's a lot easier to accuse your
opponent of like you know some
impropriety that they're forced to
defend and then just create some scandal
yeah jordan peterson was just saying or
he's been saying being honest that's it
when it comes down to it you may not
like the result tomorrow or even
throughout the years but it is the
greatest most powerful thing you can do
it doesn't sell in politics no i i think
it's uh um
honorable and i i agree with jordan you
know in that sense that we should have
scruples we should
be focusing on doing good but come on do
you really think that the average person
in politics
would agree with peterson literally they
might publicly be like that's
that's a great thing to say jordan we
all got to be honest and he's got his
hand behind his back with his fingers
crossed that's interesting
it is powerful like if you're ever
honest about something you're ashamed of
publicly it it hurts and you become made
fun of and but then you become more
powerful and calm in who you are
but it can also get you murdered and
arrested and like thrown under the like
just devastated for saying what society
didn't want you to say
there are some things that you can't
tell the truth about right so
in terms of military capabilities if
we're looking at war with china
obviously we're gonna have confidential
info top secret information confidential
classified things because if it gets out
what kind of weapons we have and where
they're going then it puts us at a very
serious advantage for
potential military conflict that i
understand you know uh that i understand
why sometimes we classify information
so there's a there's a very serious
challenge we have in this country of how
you actually justify the wars we do
without revealing too much that could
compromise security of this country
i just happen to think you know most of
the stuff we hear about from these
people they're like
they get caught lying and enriching
themselves so i just don't believe
that our the political class are good
people and in any right
and uh there's a small handful ron
paul's cool dude yeah his kid's a good
dude
you know there's a few other thomas
massey's cool kelsey gabbard's pretty
cool
they don't have to be right about
everything but it's like are they honest
and i think they are unfortunately it's
like five
people out of 535 people your name
aren't even in politics anymore
ron and tulsa dad who else do we have i
i don't know man because cringe is all
right i think he's wrong about a lot but
he's all right
and i i think one of the issues with the
the next issue is you might have some
honest people but then you get some
honest people who are like really wrong
you know did crenshaw support red flags
yeah tulsi gabbard opposed nuclear power
i think they're both great but
even then it's like you know i guess if
they're honest i'd rather have an honest
politician
who's wrong than a crooked politician
who's telling me what i want to hear
well i think senator tim scott from what
i can tell is pretty honest
um i used to be a huge fan of
congressman troy gowdy
oh yes um and he actually told me
because i asked him like before i
started to run i was like so what do you
think about this you know and he's like
no he said i would never you couldn't
pay me enough to go back to capitol hill
he said they're all just terrible people
and
he said you know i didn't get anything
done he said look at what happened with
the benghazi committee hearings
he said we could have a hearing to her
blue in the face it doesn't do anything
it's true no one's held accountable or
was it scott or um congressman trey
gowdy yeah
tim's guy's pretty cool i like that guy
yeah when he when he came out and was
leading the charge on police reform
i i thought that was a very good faith
effort on the part of republicans of
course the democrats
didn't care because they needed to
weaponize this stuff you know
they can't have a black republican
coming on saying okay we'll do police
reform no no
we need to tell everybody you're racist
so we can get more votes exactly
see trey gowdy was telling you it's just
he wouldn't go back it was
no he even did some interviews there
like on youtube somewhere but he said
you there's no way he said there's no
way he also has a podcast and i remember
he used to be a prosecutor and he used
to bring the
fire and those um hearings and i
remember just being blown away every
single time
and there's something about these guys
who can make the strong arguments that
have horrible hair and he was one of
those ones
but i love him to death he's one of
those people who told the truth and
didn't ultimately fit in because of that
right right and he said it's it's hard
because you're going up against this
machine
and he said i just i'd rather just go
back and practice law
and then i could actually hold criminals
accountable can i be a little bit
optimistic though because we you know
we do we do get a new england um a
little bit optimism
we're gonna have a good laugh everybody
and and you may think you're up against
this gigantic machine maybe it's like
mechagodzilla do you guys see the new
congress of godzilla or whatever
mechagodzilla and then you realize you
know
back to michael mouse's point about
these people are really dumb ladies and
gentlemen
we have a couple of gaffes we're gonna
start with one you may have already
heard
from fox business biden says americans
earning less than four hundred thousand
dollars will not pay a single penny in
taxes
i'm good all right but this guy is the
president and the leader of the
democratic party
i'm kind of like okay you know the
machine is like
it's like rusty yeah there's a bunch of
bent spokes and like
steams coming out one side and you're
like oh there's a big machine
but i think it's about to fall apart
so i did you see this thing from the
forehead so
okay my favorite thing about this is how
the media goes he didn't really mean it
was an accident
yes whoa whoa whoa whoa spoke how do you
know he misspoke
how do you know it was an accident maybe
he's trolling how messed up is it
that all journalists immediately and
most people just
just assume that joe biden is struggling
to speak clearly
i have not heard the word misspoke so
many times as i have in the last
two years the word is so overused right
now you ready for the next one
oh boy biden repeatedly repeatedly says
vaccine.gum
instead of vaccine.gov and ccd
instead of cdc when reading out new
coveted website
is it possible that so for one i think a
lot of people would say that biden is
just he's he's getting on his in years
and
he can't speak properly and he's not all
there or is it possible that
you remember in the debate when he told
people to like turn on the record player
or whatever
for like their kids yeah maybe he just
genuinely doesn't know what dot gov
is and so he's saying dot gum because he
heard someone say
it's not gov dot gov and he goes gum gum
i got it
he doesn't know what dot whatever is
well do you remember when he was
supposed to give the number that you
were supposed to text
oh gosh yeah yeah three three oh three
three
oh three three oh
dude ain't there you get it yeah i do
kind of feel bad but then i remember
that he's a crooked you know
corrupt politician so i'm kind of like
eh you know it balances itself out i
guess
i feel bad because i cause i can't stand
it
but then i feel worse because he's the
american president yes
there's actual trouble on the globe i
just say what are the other foreign
what are they thinking right now what
are they thinking this guy is out of
control but i you know what i put it out
after i saw that video about the four
hundred thousand
you know people not having to be a taxes
you know when he announced that he was
going to run
he said he went to president obama and
told him about it and president obama's
response was joe you don't have to do
this you don't have to do that i thought
that right there was the red flag that i
needed you know what i mean i think he
was trying to tell him look
you can't do this but the dnc i don't
think they really had anyone else to run
because after the first debate you know
camelot did okay
and then she was hitting that one
percent after tulsi gabbard
murdered her basically yeah here's what
here's what i love
is that the dnc is sitting around
and there and they're probably like
talking like what do we do to beat trump
and the one consultant goes listen we
got a lot of people who hate trump
cnn runs negative press all the time we
can put
anybody on this ticket and they're going
to win and then someone goes
what about kamala nope nope that's the
not her uh how about joe biden we'll do
kamala on the ticket with him but
she can't lead the ticket she would
actually lose out of all of the
like think about this kamala harris
doesn't win a single delegate
and the dnc thinks you know they have
all of the the moderate democrats booty
judge and you know whatever drop
out and endorse biden biden was the
like milk toast guy that they that they
needed
and and the atlantic wrote that article
they said stay alive joe biden remember
this
yeah all we need is your corporeal form
yeah wow
i'm like inspiring yeah
now you got a guy who who like the other
day he was like i'm gonna answer
questions i'm gonna get in trouble if i
stay any longer
yeah get in trouble with who yeah what
are you talking about you're the
president
man that's so creepy yeah yeah i thought
honestly that senator
elizabeth warren was gonna try to put up
somewhat of a fight i did too
uh and then she just folded like
everybody else i'm so excited for
the day when a president will do the
thing give the address and then go home
and then live stream dinner with his
friends
or her friends i don't care yeah and so
it's just a
dude and that's when i said i'll uphold
the constitution
[Laughter]
high five he has friends yeah right
exactly
i love humans there's gonna be like it
needs to be like a moral backbone
you see you see him go to his buddy's
garage to play poker and there's like a
guy in a pink polo and khakis with a
shirt tucked in smoking a cigar he goes
i love that part where you said you'd
uphold the constitution
brilliant and they all laugh and then
just like crack open you know some
champagne
yeah something yeah yeah but uh um i
i i mean one thing i'm excited for and
i'm wondering if you guys
you know when do you think it'll come
about turn it on chapter pressure oh
yeah when it what you know when can we
get that trunan on a shop at a pressure
and some battlecast characters we're in
the midst of it
i think so too i'm afraid yeah acting as
planned for true anonymous java the
pressure can we just like
no but real quick i mean i know that was
funny and everyone laughed but think
about the serious nature of
the president of the united states
literally said
truin and nana shabba de pressure on tv
i listened to that over and over again
to figure out what he was saying i have
no idea
i still don't know true international
cooperation under pressure
but that's like we're trying to read his
mind on this one
yeah what is what is an american this is
what freaks me out about people
who voted for the guy and now don't pay
attention to politics this is why
starship
troopers start to like sound better and
better are you familiar with like
starship troopers
i kind of know yes uh service guarantees
citizenship
you've got to serve for two years in
some capacity in order to be able to
vote
and i've never i've never actually
outright said like that's the way like a
lot of people have
but man when you see people at a biden
rally
and biden goes shoot it on a shop at a
pressure and they go
and cheer for it i'm like man like
who thinks it's good that those people
are gonna vote
um well they got the same thing i think
remember when dr
jill biden was at an event she tried to
speak spanish yes
and everyone was like that makes no
sense but they still applauded her
and yeah what did she say i don't know
what she was trying to say but it was
like
yes we can or something yeah it was
terrible
wow people cheer for it yeah that's why
we have one of these pictures i think
right right behind ian actually is one
of my f no no to the left
one of my favorite uh uh pieces of
artwork from george alex opolis
it's uh you can see it just to the left
of of ian right there it's joe biden
and a woman hands a little girl to bite
in the little girl is scared and
terrified
but everyone around they're all cheering
biden then opens his gigantic monster
mouth 180 degrees
and holds a little girl over his mouth
and everyone's giving thumbs up
then he eats the he consumes a little
girl then gives a thumbs up
what i love about it is how everyone is
celebrating behind him yes
it's ridiculous silly ginge uh
uh what is it uh jinji ito is that his
name like horror-esque
nonsense but what i think is really
captured here is how
biden could literally be saying
gibberish and drooling on his mouth and
people are cheering for it
he said he was going to get us batted
care and people started going
yay like yeah
i mean sure at least trump would say
build the wall you understand what build
the wall meant
it's like okay we're not going to get a
big beautiful wall from see the shining
sea but at least that's a co
like a like there's there's it's a
thought it's a thought you can define
words yeah
we it used to be such a like a like a
a threat there was such a threat in the
world and we as
we created this country to kind of i
mean
solve that at least you saw world war ii
when hitler started
invading poland and things when people
were terrified that the nazi germany was
going to conquer the world
it was like we had to rally and now
we've got this crap
and it's i'm not i don't want a threat
imagine like so so they
the left says climate change climate
change climate change there was a really
funny post i can't remember who
who who said it but um they were like
kamala harris is going to address the
border crisis
and they were like it's going to be
climate change no matter what and then
kamala harris comes out and says climate
change is causing people to move yeah
it's like okay
like i think there there is a there's a
we had a really smart fella on it was
one of a
friend of luke's he was a phd
pathologist and he said that there's you
know
um insect species collapse these are
very serious problems we're worried
about it
and i'm like i think you know we got to
be careful and protect the environment
and do all these things
now imagine these people are coming out
telling us there's this very serious
crisis we have nine years left
and they elect him i'm like i you know
i'm i'm sorry it's very difficult to
take you seriously
when you say we have nine years left
until there's irreparable damage that
will cause you know bring about the end
of days or just you know kill millions
or whatever or billions
and then this is your guy like the guy
he's
bad at cathcare has nothing to do with
climate change what is he even talking
about
and then to make it worse you get like
obama buying beachfront property
so i'm like y'all are making it really
hard for me to advocate for this stuff
to like talk about why we should you
know focus on green energy or nuclear
whatever
when they fly in in private jets with
massive mansions
and then they're like the world's going
to end you know greta tuneburg being
like
how dare you and aoc being like you know
we only have 12 years
here you go everybody joe biden he's the
hero who's gonna save you from this
global catastrophe
okay now hold on now i kind of feel like
they're laughing at us behind our backs
they're like and then i told them we had
nine years left so we put bite in it and
they voted for the guy and then everyone
laughs and they're all
like cracking champagne and then we're
sitting there in our living room's like
so is this it and what do we do
yeah well it's a tough show but you know
what's so funny
uh the president of honduras was not
that funny he actually came out and said
back in 2018 or 19
that to stop so many people from fleeing
you know south america if the united
states would just do trade with us
we could create so much more job
opportunity and people wouldn't be
leaving
in droves as they are and then he said
if america
just did one percent of their coffee
with us we would retain everyone
that's how much we could do and so he
says this at a conference and
it's on video people i've shared it and
they still are just like
climate change oh my gosh open the board
political power
political power uh they want political
power um i think
there's a lot of conservatives who get
it wrong i think tucker carlson did a
segment where he said that you know
the democrats want the illegal
immigrants to come in because they'll
give them citizenship and then they vote
for democrats
i don't i think it's a bit circuitous
it's probably
you know true in some respect but it's
totally irrelevant
when california lets in illegal
immigrants these people
appear on the census and they get more
electoral votes
for the presidency yeah they get more
congressional district seats
so the more it doesn't matter if these
people vote it just means they're going
to get more seats to the federal
government
and then the democrats are going to have
more votes to affect the entire country
so we got a problem and i think i think
we're getting really close to
decoupling i don't want to say peaceful
divorce as some have called it but
decoupling right we see now that there's
many different states declaring a second
amendment sanctuary
right or uh uh pro-life sanctuaries
california saying they're a sanctuary
state everybody's just basically given
the middle finger to the federal
government
if that keeps happening that what then
eventually there's no federal government
how long until i don't know texas puts
up borders you know between it and you
know oklahoma or
whatever and they're like we're a
sovereign state and we need borders now
i mean we did see checkpoints from covet
already so we're getting close huh
so am i am i crazy for thinking that
these states and these cities making
their own kind of rules and saying for
example are not going to enforce these
gun control laws
am i crazy for thinking that that's a
positive development because somebody
pointed out to me that that's kind of
what happened right before
the civil war which i was like i need to
learn more about that
but as far as i can tell cities and
states doing their own thing seems like
a positive
like a positive change right am i crazy
kim what do you think
no yeah but you know but at the same
time they're requesting so much federal
that's funny you know and it's like and
what we were talking about maybe two
years ago
trump was saying cutting off federal
funding to california because they want
to be sanctuary
i was in my mind i was kind of like
maybe that's the way to go you know what
i mean like if
if they really want to be sanctuary and
just their own little state in their own
little
country basically then just yeah you
can't get federal funding i like the
idea of kind of cutting the subtle
funding even from
maybe even cities like portland like i
think trump was threatening to do that
as well back in 2020 but i think that's
a good idea just kind of separate it out
a little bit so
so we have biden yes during this this
great catastrophe they say
is coming and what's gonna happen next
so i've been saying
that with libs go liberals going back to
sleep
they're not paying attention anymore
it's gonna be really hard for democrats
to muster up something to fight in 2022
so republicans may actually take back
the house in 2022 maybe even the senate
2024 maybe the presidency however i i
actually don't think trump should run
i think desentis should run and the
reason is donald trump
they will immediately i mean he really
gets the
look there are people i know who have
never voted who voted because of trump
if you have desantis these people are
going to be like who but my friends
donald trump is back have you seen this
here we go from the desk of donald j
trump trump has invented his
invented he has created his own twitter
no joke
donald j trump.com desk and and
trump has just created his own twitter
and he basically posts
uh posts he votes he posts like a micro
blogging like you'd be tweeting
and so he just made his own website
it's too bad it's not integrated with
like fetiverse and mines
and well he's not gonna do this that's
one of the biggest problems of the trump
administration
he should have done this a long time ago
if he was internet savvy he'd still be
president
he would that's true yeah if the
republicans were paying attention they'd
still they'd still have retained power
but they let the big tech companies shut
them all down they let them censor all
the
most prominent trump supporters and uh
there you go now you end up with trump's
most
uh you know prominent supporters is gone
that advocacy that that pr that free
press
gone and trump needed it
what's this website j trump trump.com
com slash desk and you can actually post
to facebook and twitter
huh it took him a long time to actually
make something very very simple it's
another issue
i know he should have had this during
his presidency and
to be honest he should have used you
know gab or parlor or something
because that then it would have forced
the media to all of them should use all
of them it would have forced the media
to cover these other these other
platforms
and then people would have signed up for
them and then it would have taken away a
lot of the power from the from the big
tech oligarchs
it's unfortunate there was an
opportunity for it it didn't happen
yeah well i i never loved
you know everybody trump surrounds
himself with you know
i'll be honest about that uh but the
same people are well-rounded they're
just in mar-a-lago they just all
move from the white house to mar-a-lago
oh
it's like the same crew um so i think
you know
unfortunately do you remember brad
pascal oh yeah
pascal parscale i think he was tech
savvy
but then remember he left so there was
yeah so yes so yeah so he hasn't been
down to mar-a-lago so he hasn't been
helping him but i think that was his his
tech savvy guy
yeah uh i think it was over the nebraska
thing
yeah where uh oh yeah yeah we had like a
million rsvps
and then trump went to this rally and
only like six thousand seven thousand
people showed up
and said this massive overflow and the
problem was that they told everyone to
rsvp anyway
just to show your support and so when
they got a million rsvps they're like
wow people really want to see trump
and people didn't come like who's
[ __ ] several you know seven thousand
people i think showed up
yeah it's not bad but it's not a million
i was humiliated trump what he should
have done
is said because of kovat we're all going
to do a very small gathering and then he
would have said we sold out immediately
instead they said we're going to have a
million people and then you know million
people didn't show up
because he's like coven so yeah
well i also thought there were you know
people getting fake tickets
because it's free you know you don't
have to pay for it yeah but
no there's an infinite number of tickets
it was first come first serve
so a bunch of these tick tock kids were
like we're the one who did it and
tricked trump and it's like you you
didn't
you just helped him get press yeah
claiming hit all these tickets because
the tickets are free and it's first come
first served you show up
john if you have a ticket people didn't
show up probably because of coven
yeah yeah well over at fox news we have
another story
house candidate suing fec over in action
on complaint against twitter says blue
check
of value in campaigns so this this this
all ties in
you know donald trump has created his
own website i think it's a smart move i
think we should all do it
the one of the reasons we started
timcast.com and we should have started a
long time ago
is that there are things youtube doesn't
allow us to talk about there are certain
opinions you can't
say on facebook and and twitter and
there's certain work you can't do
project veritas doing respectable and
legitimate journalism
they get removed for complete completely
dubious reasons just total bs reasons
they're made up
now veritas is suing because of it this
is interesting though
a house candidate is suing fec because
they didn't do anything basically
arguing that twitter giving blue check
marks
to their to her rivals was effectively
giving them
something of value to help their
campaign and i think it's true yeah
the verified check mark is an
endorsement it's a straight-up
endorsement i saw a tweet today where
someone was like and who are you
mister i don't have a check mark why why
should we even listen
brutal where's my check mark twitter
yeah because if you're verified you're
an official personality of the
of the uh i don't know of of
mainstream culture whatever you describe
it that's wild you've been knighted by
they're just so yeah well they wouldn't
verify james o'keefe
that's hideous and he had almost a
million followers and they banned him
because they didn't want to endorse him
that's the funny thing about it they're
like it's not an endorsement
but it's an endorsement yeah it is
arbitrarily given by twitter
oh yeah or if a corporation asks for it
depending on the corporation
so um i got verified on twitter because
how big was your channel when i i had
twitter my channel your twitter page
rather it's like
35 000 followers and vice called twitter
and said verify them
oh that's it the corporate in yep i got
a job advice
and i wasn't verified and there are
people saying like you know tim pool
gets millions of views covering all
these major events
been featuring all these magazines why
won't twitter verify them because i
wasn't establishment approved
i got a job advice and they went we got
you five minutes later i was verified
boom that's how it works well so i was
only verified because i was a
candidate for congress what's
interesting though is
afterwards they actually took some blue
checks away
from some conservatives now anna paulina
remember she ran in florida
she's the one yeah oh okay yeah because
she wouldn't they wouldn't give her a
blue check and she was a candidate i'm
like
what is going on so did you think that
it helped you with your campaign to have
a blue check do you find it useful
um at least they could verify me from
the fake accounts
right like it's not just that you get
you get special access
oh yes and we could post longer videos
you could do
you know you could message other blue
checks
so you know excuse me
sorry i have such bad allergies so like
i could ask you know
burtis owens or somebody else to share
my post it also have blue checks
you know because even if we don't follow
each other it's still i can communicate
with them
yeah yeah and you you have uh uh you can
sort by verified and
there's there's a bunch of things you
can do with a with a ver with
verification you can't do so they're
literally providing
functionality to only certain candidates
and and and
beyond that like the this law in florida
it's amazing i don't know if desantis
has signed it yet
i don't want to have to i don't want to
have to do it but we might have to
relocate to florida
it's so muggy i know flora is awful man
why is it that they have
a good governor you know he's trying to
get people to go there because think
about sex
think about this this way for the people
who live in the big cities
in florida everything's open you just
walk around you go to the movies you do
your thing
but now they're passing this law where
if you're a journalistic enterprise that
operates in florida
you actually have grounds to sue to get
your account unrestricted
if these big tech companies try and try
and stop you i would if i was zuckerberg
i would just
i'd be looking at ways to get out of
florida right now
sad how do you not punish this punish
the citizenry for the idiot governor
sure
he's an idiot but that they would have
mentality they would have to block all
florida ip dresses
and then and then what then make them
suffer
but don't they make them tracks twitter
they wouldn't do it they can do whatever
they want
about their bottom line what's it going
to cost the corporation
i think what would happen is if if you
know florida passes this
i don't know if it's it's i don't know i
know it's past the house and the senate
i don't know if santa's assigned it
but i believe the moment he does you're
going to get
i mean how many people live in the state
of florida i don't know
do you know does anybody know you want
to
look
33 seems a bit high really okay i'm
going to go 24 million
that seems better it's 21.4 eight okay
so
you are closer and you lose i was
wearing okay so
how many of them are conservative right
it's a 50 50 conservative state
so let's say about half you got 10
million people how many of them are
savvy and actually pay attention
probably substantially less probably
around 20 because that's what we see
with twitter user base
so now you have about two we're looking
at like two million people
how many of them can immediately just
file a lawsuit against facebook twitter
as soon as this law is signed into
effect
20 10. 10 of them are primed and ready
to sue
and so facebook is going to be dealing
with an onslaught twitter youtube
they're gonna be dealing google
with an onslaught of a whole bunch of
regular people who don't have big
accounts who all of a sudden have
who are empowered by their government to
file a challenge against these big tech
companies
and facebook's gonna have to pay for it
now you mentioned that
these big companies if you were
zuckerberg would find a way to cut off
florida yeah i don't think so you know
why
because if they did the people in
florida would realize they don't need
facebook
all of a sudden they would be like my
life is so much better huh
facebook is awful imagine if all of a
sudden twitter was gone from florida i
might move there just for that
because all of a sudden people are going
to be like i'm not hearing the screaming
anymore
and they're being imagine someone being
like
well if if you have a problem with doing
hardcore drugs and maybe i won't give
you any more the drug dealer would be
he's not going to drug deal is not going
to cut his own business off imagine
facebook is also instagram
imagine all the teen girls in florida
miami who all of a sudden can't do
instagram
and they all said the depression
alleviates they get back to
their normal lives facebook can't have
that facebook can't have large
swaths of people all of a sudden
realizing social media is a problem
so what do they do unban people it's
better to have laura loomer on facebook
than to cut 20 million users off 20 21
million users
and then have people start realizing
that social media sucks
i think social media is awesome but it's
all on how you use it you kind of get
what you give with social media 100
i don't know i if it's going to cost
them the lawsuit after lawsuit and they
end up having to pay billions of dollars
and settlements
for lawsuits it might be cheaper i don't
know if they care much about the optics
when it comes to the money it would make
a fiscal it'll be interesting because
there will be a federal challenge to it
that it violates their free speech
rights it violates section 230
but it depends um you know because we
had we had will chamberlain on he
basically said
the supreme court might defer to
protecting speech
rather than suppressing it so if the
option is
you know this person is banned from
platforms they can't speak and
this company wants to restrict their
speech we should defer to the state law
saying speech should be protected
so allow them to have their platform
it'll be really interesting
but the law in florida can only affect
florida so we need the 34 other
republican controlled states to do the
exact same thing
so i guess if you live in a republican
controlled state
just start calling them and say just do
whatever desantis is doing
because he's he apparently is somebody's
paying attention or at least has people
who are paying attention
far from perfect mind you there's a
bunch of things he's been heavily
criticized for and he should be
but there are many like this this social
media thing i think is just
absolutely imperative on the other side
if facebook didn't
go that route i think this could cause
like a a lightning storm of
behavioral change in governments across
the country like state by state like
next year we'd see two more states adopt
this
precedent yeah they should all be doing
it right now yeah they're all
you know look you live in one of these
red states
how long until they bring in a far-left
district attorney
because social media restricts the
ability from of conservatives to warn
about the stuff
you're conservative you're prominent
you're very active and then you make a
post and then you're gone
and then you can't warn people because
they're they're not going they're not
going to church to communicate they're
not going to the town town city hall
anymore town hall
they're not going to city center they're
going on facebook they're getting their
information funneled through
leftist hardcore leftist organizations
san francisco i believe
is the most democratically isolated
uh re place in the country the new york
times did this really interesting
are you in a bubble thing and they say
san francisco is where
you are unlikely to meet a republican
extremely unlikely to find a republican
so imagine those are the people who
control social media
so if you live in west virginia or texas
don't be surprised
when people believe insane far left woke
cult stuff
because their opinions are being put
through a far left filter
if republicans in these states don't
take action you're gonna be gone
yeah well you know i was i'm like on the
fence with it
because it's like there's got to be
another way i just i feel like i could
just
keep thinking on it but for me it's
still it's leading toward a big
government
and i just gotta figure it out
government
because now they're saying you know
because i guess social media platforms
you know are private correct
and so if you're putting fines on these
private
companies you know where does it end
say a democrat gets an office and
decides to do the same thing
to conservative private businesses
yeah i just feel like there's just
there's got to be another way to hold
them accountable but i see what you're
saying
i got a lot of people that push back on
me for saying that but i just
i don't know the law says that they have
to at least have i think 100 million
active users
okay that that's like three companies
so if you have massive multinational
i'll put it i'll put it this way
uh one way to look at it is what's
better big government or
a tech platform with foreign investors
operating in foreign countries
allowing foreign actors to influence our
elections but conservatives get banned
facebook twitter reddit wikipedia etc
allow
australians to post their unfettered
leftist opinions on our platforms to
influence americans
but laura loomer's banned i don't i
don't care how how how much you don't
like her
she's an american citizen and her
discourse matters
infinitely more than a new zealander but
that person in new zealand can go on
twitter and post
all the crazy leftist stuff they want
laura loomer can't how come she got
banned
oh man uh a bunch of different reasons i
guess i don't know i don't remember
oh for twitter was because she
criticized ilhan omar oh yeah
uh uh specifically about i can't
remember exactly
but had something to do with her
religious practices or something
and i think you should be allowed to
criticize a politician well face to face
a hundred percent
that's the great part about being an
american in free speech is you're
allowed to criticize each other well
it's just
yeah twitter is the platform by which we
have political discourse
it should be allowed but regardless if
if the answer is either we have a big
american government or we have
active participation in our elections
from foreign citizens
i'd rather have regulation from the
american government yeah
as opposed to some you know how about
this a russian guy going on twitter and
saying
joe biden is best vote for him i'm like
okay dude you're allowed to have an
opinion you're allowed to post but
if we're going to allow foreign people
to influence our elections by
by actively posting stories and opinion
and then ban american citizens because
their opinion doesn't align with silicon
valley you got a worse off problem than
big government
you've got some version of your state by
foreign influence yeah yeah no i
definitely see where you're going with
that
and i loved your russian accent that was
the best
that was really good it probably wasn't
good at all it was because there's like
a russian guy was watching it's like it
was terrible
i bought the item yeah luke actually
speaks polish so he could probably do it
wait wait
wait wait wait he could uh but he's got
like he's got like a brooklyn polish
accent
did you ever see rounders the movie is
up it's uh
what's his name matt damon was in he's
like a poker player with that norton and
john malkovich plays a russian in it
okay
give them his mummy oh my gosh really
really great
yeah that's terrible yeah highly
suggestion we're just gonna we're gonna
jump over to this
totally unrelated segment because we
just gotta talk about it man
uh my friends is am i gonna get in
trouble
if i say the end is nigh no i don't
think so the end is nigh
there we go u.s economy is growing
quickly but flashing an inflation
warning sign prices of goods we use
every day are rising at their fastest
pace in three years with coffee up eight
percent bred up 11
and gasoline up 22 we got a chart here
from daily mail
this is amazing bacon 11 increase
unacceptable i have a story about big
bread is up eleven chicken is up ten
coffee eight eggs seven milk's only up
three percent
gas is up twenty percent corn is up
forty four percent
yep when corn goes up everything goes up
you know why feed it
we feed cows and chickens and all the
animals corn these factory farms
cotton is up 10 appliances 15 furniture
3.5
dude you know what really bothers me all
last year
i'm like we're we're borrowing money for
ourselves these massive
you know uh debt relief packages the
dollar is gonna tank
did i go and buy bitcoin no
i did i did buy in november
it takes eight months to catch up we
even talked about that last year it's
like it's gonna be eight months before
inflation starts to rock people yep and
so i'm just i'm so i'm
i'm this is the story of life for
probably everybody
i bought i i was the guy who always
jokes about the story back in 2011 i
almost bought thousands of bitcoin at 70
cents a piece and i didn't hahaha
and then it was at like 200 and tell the
same story and then it said a thousand
dollars to tell the same story then it
said
five thousand and eventually it's just
like maybe at some point i should just
buy a lot of bitcoin i don't i don't i
just
and so so now a year ago i'm like the
inflation is gonna hit
you just you gotta understand lumber is
up between 250 and 600 percent
steel is skyrocketing the price of
everything is going up
hyperinflation is is a serious fear and
we've got numerous reports the market is
there's a market crash looming so some
investors are saying that they're
they're
they're uh bearish and they think a 30
hit to the market this year
so i hear all this i report on all of
this
i watch the ridiculous money printing i
didn't go
i did did what i did in bitcoin but then
you did
a little bit you could have went deep i
could have went deep i could have been
like
you still i'm reporting on all this
stuff and paying attention i should buy
a lot
and then so what happens is in november
bitcoin's at fifteen thousand dollars
and i'm like wow that's so incredibly
high
you know so i'll maybe i'll just buy a
little bit and then it goes up to forty
thousand dollars
like wow that's so incredibly high i'm
not gonna buy anymore
never never said sixty thousand dollars
you can always print more money and make
the value of everything else go up
that's just happening yeah
so there's gonna be a big ripple effect
and
it's gonna get bigger when you were
given these numbers nine percent eight
percent
is that in the last 12 months right now
like are they up 10
from last year at this time uh they
don't say just says
from labor statistics uh okay from last
year probably
yeah yeah i was looking up at the
inflation rate
and they're like the inflation rate is
1.7
and i think that's just the rate that
the federal reserve decides to charge
interest at
on their loans to the banks so that's
not the actual inflation
actual inflation is very different than
inflation rate
the rate is kept artificially low
because they're like we're only gonna
but
actual inflation as you can see the cost
of of goods are like
beginning to skyrocket so i'm working
you know my office is downstairs from
the studio
one day a couple months ago ian knocks
on the door
and he's like yo dude i just bought a
bunch of doge
and i was like yeah whatever and you and
and ian's like
it's like five cents and i was like yeah
whatever
it's like i think it's gonna go up dude
i'm worried because like no no you
bought it like nine cents
right since yeah then it went down and
you're like but i'm gonna hold it and
see what happens
and then i'm like i'm like ian get out
of here i don't care about your meme
coin doge whatever nonsense i'm not
buying
and now it's at 60 cents or 60
so 57 at the beginning of the show what
was it it hit 16.
earlier today yeah you got the power of
elon musk and starship martial
well so i think there's two a couple
things here
people are trying to find a place to put
their dollars because
you got buying power right now at the
dollar and we're watching it
go down think about let me do some
simple uh meth analogy for all y'all we
have
here on this daily mail thing it says
chicken up 10
that means if you want to buy a chicken
you have to work
10 more than you did last year right
so that means if a chicken normally
takes one hour of labor
tack on another six minutes to that work
you got to do so that stuff adds up
now you're looking at chicken bread
bacon everything
you've got to work 10 to 20 more corn is
44
when when that ripples through the
chicken because they feed chicken and
cows and all this factory farm corn and
even fish
the price of everything is going to go
up because these factory farms are like
we need corn but corn is really
expensive
okay raise the price on everything else
you're gonna you're gonna be
making like somebody who makes 15 bucks
an hour right now could like buy three
chickens
and then now it's up ten percent now you
can only buy you know two and a half or
something you know i may not
i'm not doing actual math the point is
all of these numbers mean you have to
work
longer to get the same thing so people
are trying to find a place to take your
existing buying power
let's say for every hour you work you
can buy a chicken
so they're like okay all the currency i
get from this work if i put it into
bitcoin or something
then when the hyperinflation hits i'll
still be able to buy the same amount of
chicken
but if you hold the dollars you won't be
able to that was my thought
last year around may june july is when i
really started going into crypto hard
when i saw the big printing that they
did last year that two 4 trillion
printing
oh yeah and i it wasn't that i wanted to
buy bitcoin it was that i want to park
my money somewhere that wasn't going to
get deflated
so i have a i have a question you might
think i'm dumb for asking this
but genuine question about um
cryptocurrencies
when you put dollars us dollars into
cryptocurrency
how do you get it out in a way that's
not us dollars
like what like you're parking your money
there to what end how are you imagining
that so so there's minds.com mindy.com
and they have tokens these are erc20
tokens they're
they're built off of ethereum right is
that that's how it works yeah the erc20
blockchain
is what they ride on okay they're it's
different than the ethereum token it's
they're different the blockchain's
different right
so you can have a a bitcoin or
whatever it's basically like me saying
here ian i'll give you this for a dollar
and then ian takes the bottle of water
and gives me a dollar
and then ian trades the bottle of water
for a can of pepsi
okay that's all it is okay so just a
different form so
cryptocurrency is basically just a uh
non-copyable digital asset
you can trade for whatever you want to
trade it for the oakland a's will let
you buy tickets with dogecoin oh cool
wow that's awesome now we're getting
real what if what if what if
hold on bitcoin is like gold and
dogecoin becomes like cash sure
oh no not like it's over like cash
litecoin is like silver printing out
little things you can carry around
rfc you get the dogecoin app and you
just
you scan we're pretty much at the whole
scan the checkbook checkout line anyway
so yeah so think about it i think i
think dogecoin will probably
in my opinion first let me just say i do
have i bought a bunch i bought a bunch
i wish i bought substantially more i did
buy a ridiculous amount
like seven years ago when it came out as
a joke
i i have no idea where it is
yeah it's like an old computer and i was
like yeah because it was like point zero
zero
what was it like zero zero zero one
percent or i got one so angry
so when i saw it i couldn't bring myself
i i had i hate
hate refused it but what people need to
realize too
when you see your crypto portfolio going
up and you're cheering that's actually
scary
because your buying power isn't going up
i mean to a certain degree it is
obviously like a 10
increase in chicken but a 1 000 increase
in
in you know doge or whatever or like uh
what is it what is a theory about like
300 percent
oh also it's like 3 200 now yeah it was
yeah so so 1700 a couple weeks ago
well like when we had bill on the show
last time bill ottman it was a thousand
bucks
yeah for ethereum now it's at 3 200. so
yeah the gain in crypto is better than
is higher than the inflation for most of
these goods but wood i think
there was an article i read that said if
you had ten dollars in lumber in
november
that would cost you sixty dollars today
wow and i'm like that's
that's comparable to like bitcoin wow
wood
building materials it's going to get
harder and harder to buy stuff
and there's just tons of shortages
furniture is not worth more
you said that's maybe i wonder if a lot
of these things are being artificially
kept furniture's up three point five
three point five only
oh this is gonna get scary man um i
don't think people realize
that uh what will first happen all the
goods are gonna get more expensive
construction materials are gonna be more
expensive
labor won't get as expensive as quickly
after the cost of food goes up
then people are gonna be like i need
more money right but businesses can't
just snap their fingers and give more
money
i mean the leftists think they can but
they can't now i'm sure starbucks and
walmart can
sort of but small businesses can't do
that they
small business is going to be like dude
we're a coffee shop coffee's up eight
percent
i can't not we're already losing money
now i can't just
give you a raise we're already losing
eight percent off the coffee
but my groceries went up eight percent
so you got to spend 16
to take care of me now so then they have
to increase the price of coffee by
16 percent or we do trade with honduras
yeah there you go
that's where our coffee is solved that's
a great solution yeah yeah
yeah i think i think dogecoin is going
to skyrocket and
people have done the math dogecoin isn't
as like
i guess finite as bitcoin yeah what's up
with that so i don't know the full
numbers but i was reading something
where they said
like dogecoin is going to print a
ridiculous amount as opposed to bitcoins
what 21 million
yeah something like that so that means
there's going to be a massive supply of
dogecoin for trade
so dogecoin could theoretically become
like cash oh boy
i was hearing that dogecoin
automatically deflates every year
like some of it is like splits or
something from the circulation
which is a very interesting concept
where does it go i didn't
i was getting removed i don't know to be
honest i just read it like nah you're
like here's my account i have a hundred
doge and it's gone why oh no
like that's how that works i don't know
maybe it's in the mining when you trade
make trades they slowly pull it out of
the circulation or something
i mean you mean like the block chains
having or not mining rather but gas fees
and stuff
gas fees sometimes coin's not if you're
using this is not on the erc20 block
chain
dogecoin is a is a uh like a uh it's not
a fork but it's a clone of bitcoin
yeah so this was made a long time ago
interesting concept though i used to
think what if we made a money that
lost value if you didn't spend it so
that we're incentivized to keep it
circulating
you mean like us dollars yeah
and i sat on it and you spent yours and
then made a thousand more you'd still
have a thousand but i have 990 at the
end of the day that's basically what the
dollars do so they want me to move it
well what's happening now is they're
getting interest for holding it i don't
want i want to disincentivize people for
holding it
that's that's that's what they do well
they give you in they incentivize you to
hold your money now they want you to
just get richer for having money but
you're not beating inflation
like so you might not need inflation if
you slowly deflated the currency over
time
deflated yeah if you slowly if people
aren't spending and it slowly
depreciates the value of the currency
does you mean inflate the currency wait
what do you mean well like so if you
have a thousand dollars in the bank and
a day goes by and you don't spend it
you may lose a percentage of that back
to the that's called
they do that's called negative interest
rates and then so that would incentivize
people to keep the money flowing
yeah they do that sometimes when the
market's like really really bad they'll
do negative interest rates where they're
like if you keep the money in the bank
you'll lose
but rather than do it to everyone at
once just have that be built into the
currency's function
man i'm i wonder what's going to happen
with this doe stuff man
it's going to be worth uh thousand
dollars elon musk is going to go on
saturday night live
yeah and he's going to be like dogecoin
and then it's going to hit it
he goes on with the dog yes he's going
to go on toshiba
yeah maybe maybe so i think the reason
does coin is skyrocketing right now is
because
elon musk is going to go on and they
think he's going to do some doge skit
it's going to cause the price to
skyrocket that's funny
yeah i'll tell you this um i'm never
going to sell the doge
hold it dude it's funnier to have and i
don't have enough to actually matter
like i wish in 2014 i spent two grand on
doge
i think you tweeted out today there are
doge millionaires i mean that's kind of
obvious
yeah but like there are probably a lot
of them dude when doge went to like
three or four cents i'm sure some person
was like i'm gonna buy a ridiculous
amount
why not in the past i had
purchased like tens of thousands of just
garbage coins
that were like yesterday 20 tokens that
were worth like an eighth of a cent
red coin i don't know just like weird
random trash and i was like hey maybe
this will be the one that you know and
like i just never cared and i forgot
i forgot about them i did have a bunch
of dosh and i just it was worthless
like this is what happens back in the
day you have like
you know 50 bucks worth and you're like
i don't care whatever
and back then i mean 50 bucks would
would end up being like you know i don't
know what like 100 grand or something
today in dogecoin
some ridiculous amount well look i don't
know what's going to happen with
all this inflation stuff they're trying
to act like it's a good thing it means
wages will go up before depression
yeah look at the history of the great
depression they were the week before the
stock market collapsed they were talking
about how great it was
what a good time to buy stocks it was
right take out loans and buy stocks on
loans
post your earnings as collateral yeah
this is so annoying because the economy
has
way too many moving parts to say
something isn't positive
you have no way of knowing if it's going
to affect 15 other different things
negatively
yes they can lie too they can blatantly
tell you it's a safe
good time for your investments and not
get on the hook for it i do it on tv
crashes it's crazy
we're gonna go to super chats if you
have not already you must
smash that like button if you truly
enjoy this show and subscribe to this
channel
and follow us on instagram at tim cast
irl
and facebook facebook.comcast.irl where
you can see little clips from the show
and share them and it helps you know
just basically promote the show
and uh become a member at teamcast.com
to get access to our exclusive members
only segments we'll have one up tonight
around 11 p.m
and uh now we will read your super chats
all right sam trendy j says hi kim what
is your favorite aspect of the blm
movement
much love for much love from vancouver
canada i find
your interestingly inspiration to me so
thanks for that
oh thank you hello to you um
so bl he's asking about what do i like
about beyonce what's your favorite
aspect of the blm movement
uh geez
is there anything good about them i
don't think so they're passionate
they are passionate they are passionate
um
i guess they're good at organizing
people
not we don't seem to do very well on the
conservative side
very true there's that christopher cavey
says kim you are my absolute hero for
calling
joy behar out on air and her own show
thank you from christopher cavey
thank you christopher that day gave me
so much joy
today honestly i
i wanted to be so nice and polite that
day
and then she just kept going and kept
pushing my buttons and i was just like
i've had enough you know and so i was i
was happy to do it but
thank you i appreciate that public
service yeah
pickle o pickler of worlds pickle
oh pickler of worlds says i just want to
say thank you to the most wonderful
woman ever
thank you to my wife on our anniversary
congratulations happy anniversary
he tried to they tried to get me on this
one but they didn't do a good enough job
so uh but i'm going to read it anyway
rampton says the first chet's name
was knight nightingale mori but did you
know that speechless controlling words
controlling minds by michael knowles is
available for pre-order
also i got my tim foil gorilla shirt so
i caught that one this time because
they've been like tricking me into
promoting michael knowles's book
i love it and it's it's if you're a
social media admin you know they'll
start a thing off
right real innocuous things and then
like yeah i'm not going but
i saw the tinfoil gorilla shirt uh at
the end and i was like okay they're
buying the tim sherry we can we'll shout
out michael knowles book
speechless yeah yeah yeah it's on sale
for pre-order it is yeah
so i hear repeat and uh we we we gotta
we gotta figure out what the next uh
you know a bit of merch is gonna be we
got the our pillow is posted up right
now so make sure you go to timcast.com
click store if you want to see all the
crazy stuff we got the tin foil no no
the tinfoil grill's gone
but we do have the diamond hands gorilla
we need to make a doge gorilla one
yes yeah we need to make we maybe maybe
make the head doge
like the gorilla petting the dog
it's just a cartoon of a shiba inu yeah
it's just a dog yeah yeah
to the enemy and it's let's say to the
moon
yeah in a suit i think we can do that
it's got to be
wrestling a gorilla in space yeah no no
just like the same art
of the gorilla but now it'll be a shiba
inu in a suit holding money in a cigar
yes maybe i think we could do it we'll
see
right let's see some more super chats
nathan kearney says i'm in law school in
ireland i desperately want to emigrate
to america
especially to work with you guys you
guys accepting non-american applicants
um i don't know i know it's really hard
to get a visa
to get a work visa for people was it
what is it called like the
green card no no no the work visas for
non-non-americans
it's it's almost impossible because you
have to you have to prove you have to
you have to prove that you need someone
like who's not in the united states
right so like if you're trying to hire
someone to do like video
editing you gotta be like well they only
live here and i can't hire them here
because we don't but that's really
difficult to do
and you know we want to hire people here
that's that's we gotta do
tom ecko says got my signed tom mcdonald
albums the other day he changed my
message a bit but it reads
bree i will do my best to be on the tim
cast irl show this year
and he underlined best hell yeah well
there you go hey thanks
for that we'd love to have thomas i hope
we can
ernie g says great guest and cast this
makes me think of jury duty with paulie
shore
blm to the chauvin trial deep fry his
yeah okay we'll leave it there his booty
all right conor o'brien said had
anti-aapi violence call at work today
1.5 hours blm and police brutality
against bypoc mentioned five times
speakers stated riding king riots were
systematic systemically racist against
asian community
intersectional insanity man you know
look if it were me
i would just i would interrupt these and
i would accuse everything they say of
being racist
just like like if they were like look
you can't you're not going to get a
white person on some you know hr
department being like
we think that you know the uh excuse me
i'm actually of asian descent and i want
to point out how racist it is everything
you're saying
and if you continue with this racism i'm
going to file an eoc a complaint
what are they going to do they're going
to be like uh
we have to do it okay i'm going to be
finding that complaint you you
you ignored me that's the problem with
this intersectional insanity
right everyone can basically complain
more people like tim raymond field says
i donated to kim's campaign please run
again when the time comes we need more
prominent black voices like yours in
congress
thank you so much for donating like i
don't know how
so many people across the country were
just so interested in helping baltimore
uh i guess you know they see the video
and they said you know what
we want to do something and we kept
getting letters too with every donation
they're like i can't really afford this
but i'm sending you my last 20 bucks
and you know it's like of course we're
gonna keep fighting
uh we left somebody in the bank so we
could fight again and i definitely
appreciate it
you know hopefully we can get out there
soon but you know that's why the pack is
important too
so we can really focus on flipping the
house
yeah what is it the pack what's it
called red renaissance can people
go on renaissance.com yep and you'll see
our candidates there with their bios and
then links to their websites and so you
can
donate directly to them as well i saw
somebody asking in chat why you guys are
promoting these minority figures instead
of just like
all the good candidates and i was like
we need minority figures to show that
everyone is interested in america first
right
we're not just you know against each
other like on some kind of racial divide
i think it's super important
thank you yeah and we have some
candidates that are would be considered
labeled minorities but
you know for us you know sometimes you
gotta fight fire with fire right
the democrats are always going to call
the republican racist if we don't
start reaching out to these communities
yeah
yeah and so you know me myself i know
someone was asking in the chat but you
know i'm a black woman and i felt like
i did not get support from the gop and
so i know what it feels like
and so so i wanted to get out there and
just support you know others and we have
a lot of good packs that support
everybody
club for growth is good elise
stefanottic has a great pack
you know so i really don't think it's
just minorities that are being supported
this time around we're just
making sure that everybody is supported
and we just got it through
and and then focus on taking the white
house back in 2024 yeah
right on jordan says hey tim and crew
i'm wanting to read more
can you recommend a book that has been
influential to you also have you thought
about inviting lucas botkin of the trex
arms under the show
i believe that you will have a great
conversation around 2a with him we will
look into him
um a book that has been influential to
me there's there's a book series
that um it's really really great it's
just it's it's it's meme worthy
and it's influential it's got great
characters it's about this uh this this
this um this family
and they have a baby and then there's
this this bad guy this evil guy he's
a wizard and he comes and he wants to
kill the baby because of a prophecy
but the spell rebounds and leaves a
lightning bolt scar in his head it's one
of the greatest book series ever written
and millennials it's the only book that
can reference so that's why i'm
referencing it
i don't know what you're talking about
oh i know you're talking about it
i would um recommend jurassic park
by michael crichton but then the movie
came out so it might not be the same
experience
i had i read it before the movie okay i
really
asked uh literature i would i would say
so i can't remember what the book is
called but i read
stephen king's collection of shorts i
wouldn't call it influential but i
enjoyed secret window
the movie very different from the book
the book was like it's a short story
the story was like creepy and legit and
the movie was kind of just like okay
yeah i think that's how jurassic park
turned out yeah because the book was
amazing yeah uh just so visceral
read manga what about you kim yeah
so i read a lot of autobiographies
that's kind of what interests me
believe it or not i'm not a huge fan of
the late john mccain but i loved his
book not a huge fan interesting
yeah what was it about just his whole
life story
you know when he went to war yeah
dude when he was being waterboarded like
when you read about that section alone
you're like
gosh this guy's been through everything
yeah
so all right black czar says appellate
courts bend over backwards to uphold
criminal verdicts
just to read some judgments x was bad
but it wasn't bad enough to have
affected the verdict is it
is the common refrain and that's in
normal cases do not expect much for
for chauvin no they're going to be like
we understand the whole thing was
corrupt and crooked but uh we're gonna
throw them in the hole anyway
the lukewarm gamer says last episode you
said you don't know if you could kill
someone in self-defense because ending a
unique human would be hard
would be too hard that sounds quite
pro-life of you may uh
maybe you're having a realization uh you
mischaracterize what i said
i didn't say that i didn't know if i
could kill someone i said that i would
prefer to use
the last round in my 12 gauge would be
rubber buck
to give someone a fair warning which
could put me at risk
but uh if i have to defend myself and
my friends and my family no question i
won't hesitate
i don't know if you guys have any
thoughts well i one time i
i caught a mouse in my apartment and it
was with a glue trap
and i didn't realize how horrible those
were and i found the mouse and he
basically tried to tear himself off the
glue trap and ripped his own leg off
trying to get off and he was suffering
and dying so i had to take him outside
and
put him out of his misery and i covered
it with a napkin i got a bag of dirt
from the trash and i just started
smashing him
and i just stepped on him bro i kept
going and going and going and going
because i wanted to make sure it was
dead to stop his suffering so i hear
these things were like
a man stabbed a woman 28 times and
you're like what the it's because he
wanted to make sure she wasn't suffering
crazy what crazy what people can become
when
she wasn't suffering no so they want to
kill her i think it might be to make
sure she's dead
but part of it is to just and end it as
fast as possible no no
no no no no that's what it was your
story is putting him outside of his
misery you're right
a murderer brutally murdering a woman is
like could be unrelated
yeah i'm pretty sure he's just murdering
somebody but you know if you got to
become that
not i would never suggest it but man
when people go into war that when you
listen to them tell stories afterwards
they yeah you're not
i mean you're still human but it's hard
humans are wild animals
all right remy says tim i'm a security
guard working in baltimore
now that they're not prosecuting
low-level crime my job is getting hectic
because the crazies know the cops aren't
going to come if i call
glad to see you kim you had my vote oh
thank you remy yeah
that is that's the big problem it's a
big problem and it's so crazy that our
state's attorney was just
like well we just got to get those off
the docket they're wasting our time
you know low-level crimes are still
crime
and it's crazy to me but thank you so
much uh we got to fight
it to also get her out of office as well
in my opinion and michael says the fifth
amendment
states no right may be deprived but
through due process
which means rights can be deprived
provided through due process
i would not want my daughter's rapist to
be allowed to possess a gun
i don't like personalized moral
arguments
about you know this person victimized me
therefore that should be determination
about everyone else's right to keep and
bear arms
but i understand your point i just think
that justice is supposed to be blind
i don't know if that's the correct
understanding of what it means by just
being blind but
my understanding is that it's supposed
to be that everyone is treated equally
under the law
and i think
i guess i guess the issue is a lifetime
ban on things i'm not a fan of but
maybe the issue is
i don't know i think our prison system
doesn't actually reform or rehabilitate
or actually deal with any of the
problems of violent offenders we just
lock them up and then say okay long
enough you're free to go and
change anything it doesn't change the
person and therein lies the bigger
problem i suppose
i don't know if if we're going to argue
that this is what you have to do to pay
penance to society
but your rights will still be deprived
then we're giving people a life sentence
i was thinking we could put um
webcams in prisons with the prisoners so
that they could communicate with like
their friends and family
over watch of guard they can though what
do you mean well just like 24 like
they'd have time whenever they want
yeah like within reason so that they can
talk with like a
psychologist so to keep them sane
healthy
you know and and hopefully a better
person when they
finish their sentence
mchatten says have you guys heard of
dark journalist ufos atlanta cia lots of
solid info about thing in the present
and
past trump connected to nikola tesla and
van aver bush ufo files are at the
center interesting
cookie monster says you're really behind
on the conspiracy ufo stuff
you have to have on dr stephen grier to
get up to speed with what's really up
with ufos
that's birds oh i heard that dr greer
yeah
sonny james says tim i disagree with
talking any taxing okay
anyone making over 400k let biden where
uh where are these entrepreneurs going
to run to lol look at jack ma
every other country's business married
to government why shouldn't ours be musk
learned this too
so we we shouldn't tax people making
over 400k
i don't know i think we should be taxing
the rich a lot of money i just don't the
problem is
that's a half-baked solution the
government just getting more money
doesn't solve any problems that's also a
problem
right not having a bunch of rich people
manipulate our elections and
also i don't i don't understand why
people really care about the rich people
i don't get it
like oh no bezos he's got so much money
the wealth tax is stupid it makes no
sense
don't get me wrong but it's really weird
for me to see people being like i think
tom steyer should have more billions of
dollars to elect democratic das
to subvert the the will of the working
class and take away our gun rights
i'm like i i don't i think it's like
wishful thinking i think they think one
day
they're going to be the rich the wealthy
and so they're like we don't want this
because what day my day will come
i don't even i don't even think that
even honestly
because i know a lot of rich people they
don't care they're like i don't know i
pay taxes
and i'm like yeah and they don't care
they're like dude like when you have
five million dollars and you pay
you know two to like 2.2 million taxes
they're like i don't know i have two
million dollars in cash
they don't even look at it most of them
the cpa handles it and they say this is
how much you owe they say okay
goodbye yeah right so it's weird that
like
we've got a problem with mostly
left-wing ultra-billionaires
screwing at everything and it's the
conservatives defending them yeah
bloomberg's not a good person
tom steyer is not a good person george
soros is not a good person the koch
brothers not fans either but
you know they did cato institute so i'll
give him respect for that
all right where are we at oh trinidad a
shop at a pressure
name changer says tim it's code for help
me they are pressuring me
they got a tape of me with with young
dems it's not what you think i'm a good
guy help
reminds me of rick and morty when bird
person is like
you know that phrase that rick says
that means help i am depressed or
something like that yeah yeah
i've been great biden was trying to say
true international diplomacy through
pressure
true and ananda shaba but why is there a
shabba
shabba true international oh that's
from the national okay okay
crinson says i live in texas and i was
seeing if my manager has enforced the
mask policy
eight days of not wearing a mask at all
only one mentioned it one day
others wear it wrong and nothing should
i keep going and see where it leads me
you should follow the rules follow all
the rules
follow your local ordinances noah zemple
says tim you guys are talking about
starship troopers being possible
while dealing with a starship trooper's
administration long live
lord emperor trump uh not about being
possible i was just making a point that
like
the more i see people cheering on
trinidad shop at pressure i'm like maybe
we need
service to guarantee citizenship but you
know maybe not i don't know
far be it for me roger grigore says long
time watcher you all rock
in new york you can vote as felons as
soon as you leave prison
and relief of disability gets some gun
rights back oh interesting
i believe it's is it new hampshire where
you could actually vote while still
in prison oh wow yeah there's like three
states that does it
interesting yeah nadia shell worry no
more says i'm a huge conservative but
police
need to go and people take
responsibility for themselves
the country is going to develop into two
no matter what that's what they want
i think it's better not to fight it and
move when the time comes
i feel like the country is breaking
apart and the left is screaming defund
the police because as soon as the police
are gone the decoupling is instant
and conservatives are actually
disadvantaging themselves by supporting
a decaying
a system in decay and if they
it's it's like man the far left has
already jumped off the cliff they're
they're you know they're they're base
jumping as fast as they can they got
their wing suit ready to go
and conservatives are holding on saying
like no no no we're not gonna go we're
not gonna go it's like well they're
gonna win the race
you know my concern with what this guy
said is
that yeah like the getting rid of was
getting rid of the police or something
insinuating that and then
uh personal responsibility yeah but i
have a feeling
you've never been in war i've never been
in war but i've studied it a lot and
when you see these numbers like
17 000 men came from the west with 8 000
dudes on horseback
your personal responsibility is not
going to protect you if we get invaded
you need social order and protection we
that's so that's i mean that's what
policing is basically
i mean not for war well last resort yeah
they would fight national guard would be
deployed
yeah but last resort you'd have like
militia and local cops
it's it's i don't think war is what you
think it is ian well i just been
stunning a lot of battlefield tactics
and it's tens of thousands of of people
moving at once
and and that that's like no indication
maybe maybe thousands of years ago
even like a couple hundred the us the us
revolution
yeah but the us now wins through air
superiority it can decimate through
air spirit we can only really win by
taking but we don't have
10 000 troops marching in the desert you
know towards the taliban chinese
have have lots and lots we don't we
don't we don't do that i mean in world
war two we had u-boats storming the
beaches
but in terms of you you look at the
videos out of syria you look at videos
in the middle east
and based on the stuff i've seen in
urban conflict you can walk past a war
zone and they're not gonna
touch you like there are literally
people who are like carrying baskets of
water as bullets are flying
because they're not a target for the war
i mean what other choice do you have to
it's still extremely risky and some of
these people often they get hurt
people flee because the collateral
damage is so high but
i've been in tons of foreign urban
conflict situations where
they completely ignore me i have nothing
to do with their conflict
you can get this you know you can get
hit as a bystander so
you don't want to be there but i've
watched the apc's role in you know and
and
they do their thing and they ignore you
you're not you're not part of their
conflict
that's not true everywhere some places
might find out you're an american and
then kidnap you because they can use it
as leverage
but it's not what people think it is
it's no i can only imagine
modern war it's never what you think
it's gonna be that's what they tell you
sam t says i'm getting a dogecoin rocket
tattoo thursday cheers from denver ian
rox
that's all right have fun with that yeah
to the moon kim dab says you keep
talking about fishing by the river why
not make a tim cast fishing rod lol
i haven't actually gone fishing in a
very very long time we got to do that
i think we were talking about growing
fish here garage hydroponic is that what
it's called
oh yeah growing fish like growing them
like in a pond
like yet clean the water i don't know
that's hydroponics it's called something
like
fishery yeah salmon farm tracy bort says
thank you so much for the millions i got
from all the coins i found on your
laptop when we worked together
i know you've been looking for that
machine and then it was wrong with me to
not return it to you but you know
i actually the computer might be here
somewhere
yeah i think it might be no idea nice
whatever we'll find it
but you know yeah whatever like
i have a whole bunch of applications for
when these all these different
currencies popped up and i was like
downloading the original
apps to run and mine them aquaponics yes
aquaponics yeah oh so cool
jay park says can you have jordan
peterson on the show i'd love to have
jordan peterson on the show but i think
he's trapped in canada
so super busy as well nicholas nasty
says crypto will not protect you they
can always print more coins
silver or gold is the only way to
protect your wealth i would say
only but uh absolutely i have gold and
silver
yeah definitely i i've had gold and
silver longer than i've had
cryptocurrency for obvious reasons it's
been around
but uh i i don't have as much gold or
silver because it's a lot easier to
acquire crypto than it is gold and
silver
mm-hmm and with you know a good crypto
well i don't know but a lot of cryptos
there are only a finite
number of coins they'll tell you ahead
of time how many they're going to make
you can look at the code
you can look but they can always fork
bitcoin or something and there can be
some you know change made
all right timmy hill says
maybe tim should take the same advice
you give cops and quit youtube and
twitter in protest of their censorship
if enough people quit they might change
their ways i guess if we were at the
point
where the system was completely
untenable
and i wasn't allowed to criticize the
media at all anymore
sure like if youtube came to me and said
from now on
you're only allowed to say things that
support progressives and you can't say
any of your
any any opinions that are
pro-conservative i'd be like okay i quit
you know what i'd leave what if they
said no don't worry everything's fine
and then they demonetize your video and
then the next time they're like we're
not going to do that anymore and then
they demonetize you again
and again and again and they kept
telling you we're not going to keep
gasoline we're not going to demonetize
you but they kept demonetizing you
how long before you leave like a day
yeah
that's what is going on with these cops
they they keep making arrests and the
people are getting let go
so they keep going back to work like hey
do your job keep putting my hand in the
fire and it
won't burn yeah so right now the problem
is
the situation police and these big
cities are in is that
they're basically enforcing the law that
only ever gets applied
against regular people people who want
to go to church people who want to open
their business
conservatives and antifa except for you
know the most extreme offenders are
getting cut loose over and over again
even when they admit
they attacked a federal officer so it
got to the point
where no matter what you do you're only
empowering
lunatics then you stop however on this
show and on my social media i actually
do the opposite of that
so i'm actually heavily critical of the
media establishment and able to do so
so i think it's not the same at all
dennis gregerson says kim klasik as vp
would she i think it would be great that
would be great
on whose ticket oh that's a good
question yeah
are your top three i love governor ron
desantis
i honestly i i thought a governor ron de
santos and senator tim scott ticket
would be a good one
yeah i think that'd be great uh but yeah
i don't know who else honestly we gotta
have some better frontrunners in the
republican party yeah i mean obviously
the democrats don't have anybody but
sometimes i look at ours and i'm like
who do we have
yeah all right bill p says the notice
came out this morning
the transition from the swift financial
system to the quantum financial system
has now been completed
ian should be thrilled dude is that true
i don't know but i'm looking it up right
now thank you
interesting the quantum financial system
wow that sounds good
all right let's see let's do a we'll do
a couple more maybe
ideology says idea ology says glad to
see kim on
yes for doge it's an inflationary coin
it has no cap
it will most likely mimic cash if fully
adopted you all really need to get a
crypto expert on like george from crypto
r us ps ideology
to the moon um max kaiser and stacy
you guys know max and stacy um when are
they coming in next monday
next monday yeah max and stacey are
awesome
they are they're great people i'm going
gonna be very excited and we're gonna
talk all about all the stuff and
uh it should be interesting yeah so uh
but i'm pretty sure
they'll also have a similar opinion of
like doge's trash you know yeah i don't
think max doesn't like a lot of the
altcoins
i'm gonna go deeper he doesn't call them
all coins yeah yeah
i have an idea of what he might be yep
all right let's see roberto durin
says love your energy and attitude
kimberly we need you in government
oh thank you i feel like i'm like
halfway here tonight just because i have
like the allergies are so bad
but um no i really appreciate it uh you
know hopefully
you know like i said i'll work through
22 and we'll still try to make some
ground
and grassroots efforts 24 you never know
what's going to happen
uh but obviously we got to still keep
chipping away on the ground no matter
what
yeah but i do appreciate the voter
confidence elijah
zapeda says candace owens just asked
trump if she can be his running mate on
her show
i saw that is that true i saw it but he
said
i have an announcement coming up and
that's all he said to her
wow was she was she seriously like or as
well
it looked pretty serious i but you know
what who knows
i i don't know if candace would be
serious about running yeah or
you know what i mean i don't know all
right silently in atlanta says tim
may i thank you for promoting doge i've
tripled my force because of you i'll get
a gorilla shirt when it reaches
five times love kim you are baltimore's
new hope
so the dark side lacks new notion i
learned is
requisite variety may the fourth be with
you
well i'm not trying to promote doge so
much as just like talking about what's
going on but
yeah well my friends if you haven't
already please smash that like button
and subscribe to this channel and more
importantly
share the show with your friends if you
really do like it you can follow us on
instagram and facebook at tim cast irl
where we have clips and you can share
those really easy to share
they're short snippets so we have a
really one that went really got a ton of
shares
is james o'keefe explaining how to how
to win and fight back and stand up what
you believe in
these are the kind of messages i think
people need to hear i guess
give some hope but also it's a much
simplified version of the things we talk
about there might be like a three-minute
clip where we talk about a certain idea
so check out facebook.com
facebook.comtimcast.irl you can help by
sharing a lot of these clips and
you know helps the show but go to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have an exclusive members only segment
coming up at about 11 p.m tonight we put
them up every night
and a lot more shows to come as we build
out the website
totally new design coming soon a news
team uh is gonna we're gonna be setting
up a news room and doing all this really
cool stuff so i
i appreciate all of you guys being
members you can follow me
everywhere at tim cast my other channels
are youtube.comcast youtube.comcastnews
and we do this show live wednesday
friday at 8pm do you have anything you
want to shout out kim
yeah uh if you can go to the pax website
redwatersons.com
uh you can follow me on twitter kim k
baltimore instagram youtube and facebook
it's kimberly klasic
and yeah hopefully we'll start doing
some more
stuff in the future and i just want
people to understand like don't give up
hope you know
in 2008 we were kind of the same
position we lost the senate we lost the
house we lost the white house but
you know we came back strong with
someone like president trump so i think
we could do it again
right on thank you um hey confirmation
swift rebranded as quantum financial
swift
i think they may be looking to use time
crystals to transmit information
yeah check out time crystals everyone
interesting it's gonna blow your mind
uh you can also follow me at ian
crossland.net ian crossland along social
media
channels great great to see you kim um
good to do this thank you
and i'm gonna have to go investigate
these time crystals being used for the
monetary system
i am sarah patchwoods on twitter you
guys must join me in my quest to have
more followers and sour patch kids on
twitter
we'll see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out
you